ladies and gentlemen we're about to get
started we're going to stand for the
Pledge of Allegiance representative
buard would you please lead
us the flag the United States of America
to the stands
Nation
indivisible
jice thank you very much all right we
have three and a half hours um and as I
had mentioned before I know some of you
have signed up we have your pink cards
you will get uh first preference as soon
as I get the pink cards uh when our
clerk gets here um so please bear with
me I apologize uh some folks who were in
line the last time um we will get to you
as quickly as I can and as expeditiously
as I can um first Speaker uh
representative uh
papoi welcome thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Daniel popovic Miller I I represent
Rockingham 17 and I am a co-sponsor of
the Right to Work bill let me start my
testimony by answering a question that
I've often heard uh in the previous
testimonies why wouldn't everyone want a
union job I don't want a union job
because I do not agree that somebody
should be paid more and be given first
choice of work assignments because
they've been there for longer and they
have seniority I don't want a union job
because I want to be able to negotiate
my own contract to suit my own personal
preferences instead of having to agree
to a one-size fits all contract
negotiated by the union I was also born
and raised in a communist country I do
not take it kindly to being forced to do
something I do not willingly choose to
do there are other reasons but we only
have so much
time now I do not want a union job for
myself but I also do not want to impose
my beliefs on others I respect the
choices of people who want one and would
never prevent them from choosing to be
in a union if that is what is best for
them the bill is about protecting
everyone's right to make their own
choices we all know what's best for us
better than a government official or a
union leader this bill supports the
right of workers to voluntarily organize
in Union it just protects each worker
civil rights and freedom of Association
by prohibiting the payment of union dues
from being a required condition of
employment for the record CW CWA versus
be diminished but did not eliminate the
right of unions to collect fees from
everyone in the workplace regardless of
whether they wanted to join a union or
not the court role that the collection
and disbursement of agency's fees for
purposes other than collective
bargaining violated the rights but it
did allow the unions to collect fees
from member from non-members from for
for collective
bargaining and to come to the core of my
testimony one expression that I've heard
and I'm sure you'll hear again and again
was Free Riders who supposedly take
advantage of a federal law that forces
Union to represent all workers at a
company whether or not they pay union
dues treat unions unfairly I believe
that every person who said that believes
it is true but unfortunately that is
simply not the case federal law does not
obligate unions to represent non-members
under the National Labor Relations Act
unions can choose to represent only
their dues paying members under a
members only contract unions are only
required to represent all workers if
unions choose to take on exclusive
bargaining representation
to gain a monopoly and Union
representation in that negotiation
unit they do not do this selflessly they
use their bargaining Monopoly to
eliminate competition from other unions
they use it to gain more power of the
employer by not allowing them to
negotiate different contracts with
non-union members and they use it to
make Union contract Staples like
seniority possible by preventing Hy
performing workers harmed by those
Provisions from negotiating their own
contracts with pay based on Merit yes if
unions opt for exclusive representation
Federal Law requires Union to negotiate
equally for all workers to protect non
non-union workers from being negotiated
into lower wages or poorer working
conditions against their will member
only unions do not are not required to
represent nonmembers completely
eliminating any concern about Free
Riders to summarize unions choose to
negotiate as an exclusive representative
in in order to benefit themselves and
their members and then frankly they have
the hood spot to call the people they
coerced into being
represented by the Union Free Riders to
falsely suggest that they are somehow to
blame for a situation the union created
if Free Riders are a burden to the union
the union can eliminate them by choosing
to be a member's only Union if a union
chooses to ask for exclusive bargaining
in a right to work state they do so
knowing full well that their choice is
beneficial to them regardless of what
they call the Free Rider issue this bill
respects the right of every worker who
chooses to be a union member to become
one and enjoy the union representation
they desire and it eliminates the right
of unions to force unwilling people to
pay for services they do not want and
are coerced into using even when they
consider those Services detrimental to
themselves both are desirable policy
goals and worthy of support I would be
happy to answer any questions and I
cannot stay here as as long as I would
like I have to be an executive session
at 10:30 I would encourage anyone who
wants to talk to me about this bill to
call and text me at 603 267
4142 one last
note every time I come to a session and
I see people with signs in front of the
building I stop and talk to them I've
been this is my first term but I've
still done this about 15 times already
this is the first time when I stopped to
talk to a group of people and they asked
me whether I support the bill or not and
when I said I'm a co-sponsor they said I
don't want to talk to you I'd like to
think that that was just a few of the
members who feel more strongly I would
welcome conversations with anybody who
disagrees with my testimony I have
reconsidered my position when I was
shown to be wrong but to do that we got
to sit down and talk about it and I'm
open to being told I'm wrong I just uh
you know that takes a conversation so
I'm open to that I left some of my
business cards in there and I'll be at
the back of the building at the back of
the room as much as I can to allow for
people to uh engage thank you so much
and obviously I'll take questions thank
you for your testimony there any
representative seeing none thank you
you next pink car is my good friend Mark
Guild
good morning good morning
chairman Vice chairman MERS of the House
markward H my name's Mark Hayward I'm a
uh I'm here on behalf of the New
Hampshire news Guild we represent
journalists advertising sales reps
customer service reps and office workers
and at the New Hampshire union leader uh
we see House Bill
1377 as a grow government bill that's
going to make more work for the New
Hampshire legislature um last month I
attended the round one of this hearing
and I um heard a lot of people say we
have problems when it comes to housing
homelessness health care and um I then
we believe that the best way to address
those issues is to encourage and protect
strong middle class in this state um I
think I have a lot of union members here
so if if I can ask them a few questions
could you raise your own your hand if
you own your own house or make rental
payments on
time how about are you covered by Health
Care um either from your employer or
your
union and after A Hard Day's Work can
you go home and find time to help your
kids with their homework play ball with
them take them to dance or music classes
right these are stable members of your
communities they're responsible
individuals they work hard they don't
come here to ask for a handout they pay
their taxes hell once in a while they
might even vote
Republican um House Bill 1377 will hurt
them and the ability of our unions to
represent us some of us might fall out
of the middle class have to take a
second job um can pay bills lose the
house drugs and alcohol families fall
apart kids suffer and that means they
come here to ask not for not to keep
protect their jobs but they ask for um
for assistance and handouts right um we
all know that the biggest problems you
guys face here isn't abortion or guns or
school books it's spending and taxes
that's the hard part of your job
affordable housing expanded Medicaid
food stamps Mental Health Service is
drug and alcohol abuse why is that the
loss of the middle
class from 1983 to the present right the
number of people represented by unions
in the workforce has gone from 20% to
10% um and also during that time the
middle class has shrunk according to
research from Pew um from pre Pew
research to from about 61% to
50% also during that time time the last
40 years federal government spending has
increased from 1.7 trillion in today's
dollars to 51 trillion so it's pretty
it's pretty simple unions in the middle
class strength government growths if you
want to keep your job manageable you
want to protect the middle class in the
state you want to keep government small
protect the
unions thanks so much I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you Mr
Hayward are there any questions for the
presenter
you I can't pronounce your or I cannot
335 Bill
havy
Harvey
Harvey all right we'll keep that one
warm
here I'm not going to do any better grou
that get the because obviously very
small so you have to be patient excuse
me it's a large group that can't get
into the room so you have to be
patient I didn't think I was being
Dave
Trades thank you did I get that right
sir specul yeah close enough sir thank
you uh Mr chairman honorable committee
members my name is dve Puli I'm the
president of New Hampshire building
construction trades Council and also a
member of local 976 laborers union out
of Portsmith New Hampshire
the New Hampshire Construction and
building trade represents nearly 2,000
Working Families uh in New Hampshire we
are an umbrella organization of local
construction unions in partnership with
private contractors and small businesses
that provide high standard uh training
workers in the construction industry our
mission is to provide for these
construction projects while creating
more and fair just environment in the
construction industry the workers and
trades that my organization represent
have uh special skills and experience
which are required through years of on
the job training and education provided
by our Apprenticeship Training classes
and other training classes this
education and job training to workers is
provided through funds raised by our
local members and collected baring
agreements at zero cost to the taxpayer
this bill would be destroy the funding
and training mechanisms that would
ultimately end up costing more to our
taxpayers for money for poorly
constructed uh constructed projects and
need uh fun in for training projects for
workers who already have become
Tradesmen Our Workers are the best in
the construction business through
contracts and agreements with private
business owners the unions that make up
New Hampshire building construction
trades have created a system to staff
projects of all sizes and who have
received years of training in their
prospective Fields this is why our
workers are coveted for projects such as
construction work to be done in new
biofabrication cluster uh in the city of
Manchester um which is set to become the
global leader and regenerated tissue and
organs the biofabrication cluster which
represents uh over $40 million in
funding has entered into a memorandum of
understanding with the con uh New
Hampshire building and construction
strage for our workers to do the
construction and filling of the
facilities that will have a uh Cutting
Edge in this new
technology House Bill uh 1377 the
so-called right to work if pass would
strip workers of the uh protections of
fored provide these agreements between
two Private Business entities as well
has been in other states have passed
similar laws which also lower wages and
endanger workers and safety uh by
destroying the mechanisms we have built
through our training classes for our
highly skilled workers we see no reason
why the state should be interfering in
the business decision of two private
businesses and cannot think of another
situation where in the Live Free or Die
State the government feels need to uh
get in between employers and employees
relationship this is not the way we do
things in New Hampshire and we respect
respectfully ask the committee to vote
itl on this Bill thank you very much
thank you there any questions for the
McKenzie thank you for appearing before
the committee um so the question I have
the Building Trades are somewhat
different than a than um a plant would
be for instance so how do they how do
they come to be Union members and what
would it be like if somebody uh who took
advantage of the apprenticeship program
all of those things ended up not being a
union member uh after they after they
petition to get in the local so how do
they get in and then what would the
impact be uh thank you for your question
yeah so how they get in is to each
individual trade if uh you wanted to
become an electrician you go to the
electricians union apply for their um um
entrance there same with the iron
workers same with I mean all the trades
are pretty much the same Carpenters
laborers you go you talk to um the
business managers there you apply for
the apprenticeship programs you get sent
to school you get typically 400 hours
worth of training 4,000 uh or so hours
on the job training and if you decide
not to be a member at that point anymore
you simply St paying your dues and you
continue to you're still afforded all
the training that you got you're still
afforded any certifications that you
have so you can simply not pay your dues
and go non-union if that's what you feel
like there's no requirement stating that
you have to say a certain time frame
nothing that you have to give back or
pay back after you decide not to I mean
it's a choice you make you either
continue to pay your dues and stay a
away any other
questions repr love
thank you for taking my question thank
you Mr chair
um you know you mentioned you have quite
a few members and uh and stuff and uh
I'm guessing that you you offer good
benefits packages and and stuff uh would
you expect if this bill passes would you
be be expecting to for membership to
decrease or increase or or stay the same
uh I would like to say that I would hope
that everybody would maintain their
um
their allegiance to each individual
trade that they have and I think that
that would
probably be the case but there would be
some people that would absolutely not do
it I mean if you no longer had to pay
for your gym membership but you still
got to go to the gym I would see a lot
of people that would probably would not
pay for the gym membership um you know
if you're getting something for free
there's always that aspect of why
continue to do this and we would still
be having to represent all the people
that decided not to to pay their dues at
a cost to to all of us which would
significantly hurt the people that would
continue to maintain their
dues follow up follow up
um I've I've read where um you know
union membership actually goes up and
right to work states uh and it's because
of the the benefit P that's the the
product that that's offered um you know
would you um would you be be wanting to
buy a product that you didn't want like
say for instance if you were um allergic
to wheat bread would you want Market
Basket forcing wheat wheat bread on you
I don't see this as a forcing thing you
have a choice to join the union or not
no one's ever forced to to join a union
no one's ever come to me and said hey
you need to do this whether you like it
or not it's a choice I made um you know
that's why I don't understand what what
this bill is is like you're you're
saying that we're like forcing these
people to join unions and and we never
do like anybody who's ever come to me um
has come on their own free will I've
never said hey I'm going to call John
Smith and make him come in here for an
interview today to join to join my my
union um that's never happened in the
history i' that I've been in I've been
in for 25 years um I've never known
anybody to be forced to join a union
it's something that you do on your own
free will because you know that there's
benefits that far out way not having a
union
membership one more one more would you
believe I have you have what sir I have
been forced to join a union or lose my
job well uh I don't know what union that
would be I would think that' be highly
um pretty much unconstitutional at that
point it was a while ago so I don't I
don't know how anybody could force you
to join a union sorry that it happened
to obviously because I don't think
that's the right way a union should be
representing itself but I know of all
the trades in the construction union not
a single person has been forced to
join all right thank you very much for
your testimony thank you everybody for
Bobo
you so I'm uh here as a representative
of Gen X Construction Group also a
member of local
352 um for the past nine years I work 20
years in the non-union
sector um I can honestly state that
becoming a union member was the best
choice I I made in my career as a
construction
worker but also as a representation for
Gen X Construction I just wanted to read
this letter that we have that we've sent
in I believe you guys have all read it
our ownership has actually signed it and
sent it in during the last
meeting um as members of the New
Hampshire business community and
signatory contractors with the
Carpenters Union we are writing to
express our strong opposition to House
Bill
1377 the so-call Right to Work bill that
is currently under consideration in the
legislature we believe that right to
work is bad public policy because it
mandates government interference in a
free market and will adversely impact a
New Hampshire based business if passed
by legislator the the right to work will
intrude on our businesses ability to
freely negotiate contracts that would
determine that we determine are in the
best interest of our company that isn't
a decision the state should be making
especially here in New Hampshire houseal
Bill 1377 right to work isn't about
workers rights instead it's an effort to
weaken unions and will ultimately harm
workers our communities and our
businesses our business our business
employees more employees more than 2500
workers with good pay and competitive
benefits as building contractors we
consider the Carpenters Union a partner
and act success because they help us
deliver quality work to our clients and
the most effici ient
manner working Partnerships between the
carpenters union and construction
employers provide comprehensive reliable
skill trained and professionally
development that is desperately needed
in the construction
industry where some where some see
construction jobs as a temporary or
unattractive we see them as rewarding
careers where skills are valued and
professionalism grows through mutual
respect and
cooperation the union shares those
principles and that's why our Labor
Management apprenticeship model is the
most successful recruiting and retention
tool available to our our companies by
weakening the unions and our training
programs Right to Work would make it
harder for us to find and keep good
employees in New Hampshire and that
would hurt our companies and the state's
overall
economy we also believe that passing
right to work will also harm our
communities because studies
show that states that have passed Right
to Work have lower wages and Health Care
coverage and higher rates of poverty
pushing more people towards Public
Assistance is not something we believe
is good for our communities and
ultimately cost our state more money in
the long run states that have so-called
right to work laws also have a much
higher rate of job site injury and
death we encourage you to focus on
passing laws to improve workplace safety
not Advanced legislation that will make
our job sites more
dangerous um and on that being a
taxpaying member of the State of New
Hampshire I'm wondering why this bill
keeps coming up every two years when
it's been shot down every time this bill
would take money it would take money out
of my wallet and food off my table I
choose voluntarily to pay my dues for
representation to make sure that my life
and my safety is taken care of on a job
site the does that they help us to
negotiate that to make sure that that
happens that we're taking care of so we
can go home every night to spend time
with our family and we still have
something at the end of our career to be
able to
enjoy I'd appreciate it if you guys
really considered not approving this
legislation thank you are there any
questions for the presenter I I have one
sir you you just mentioned
um uh states with the right to work have
more um safety problems correct do you
have any information you could provide
the committee to that at this time I
don't have any handy but I'd be more
than happy to AFF on any correspondence
that you would need on that there's
there is if there's an article if
there's some kind of data I'd appreciate
it there is for sure I can make sure
that you get that all right thank you
thank you all right I'm going to look
again
Haney we do have the cards we're going
through the cards for those folks who
have signed up before try to give you
first dibs all
right representative kahill just a
suggestion Mr chair if in if this comes
back in another year or two maybe we
should ask people to write a number and
we'll pick a number just like the deli
counter let's hope we don't have to do
it
though are you Bill I am and what is
your last name sir it's Z Lang I believe
the the wrong uh last name I'm with
District Council I guess that could be
yeah sure okay all right M Mr Lang
welcome thanks for your time today um my
name is Billy Lang I'm a resident of uh
der New Hampshire taxpayer homeowner I'm
also a business rep for District Council
35 of the panners and Allied
trades um I represent over 4,000 members
in that capacity but um not just a
representative of my union I'm also a
member um here to speak against right to
work today um I'll tell you right now I
owe everything to this Union right um my
generation is having a hard time being
able to purchase a home you know having
a hard time finding careers as opposed
to jobs um and I always say the
difference between a job and a career is
that your career actually has an end
point so unions unions provide that for
me I know that some point I'm going to
be able to stop working and I'm going to
be able to retire with dignity um not
not only that but I'll tell you right
now I'm actually coming back from the
state of Florida last week I was down
there for an organizing Drive Florida is
a right to work state so this last week
I've had to listen to the hardships and
the horrors of workers in a state that
uh have been in uh employed by their
employer for going on 10 15 years and
they're still making they just broke $15
an hour on average right to work states
employees make 15% less than uh than
states without right to work laws I'm
asking you to think today about the
people that you live with in the state
of New Hampshire and which ones of them
can take a 15% pay cut um this state is
already you know there's a misconception
that it's it's a very affordable place
to live everybody in here knows that
that's not true the the cost of living
is not any different than it is in any
of the surrounding states that are not
right to work we can't afford to take a
15% pay cut we can't afford more
contractors coming in here and more
employeers coming in here thinking that
they can get away with whatever they
want with the working class in the state
of New Hampshire um that's all I got
today thank you for your time any
questions for Mr Lang I have two for you
please one's a
comment I really like what you just said
I've never heard that before the
difference between a job and a career so
I going to use that so I appreciate that
thank piece of wisdom um the second
um do do you work here in in the state
of New Hampshire I do okay thank you
very much you're welcome any other
questions uh actually I'm going to give
this to my political director and he'll
handle it from here thank you right
thank you I'm looking I'm trying to to
deal with a few these pink cards here
from the last time is City councelor
Katherine Hill Karen Hill here from
Hill I don't think
Hill all right Tracy
stclair
right yes please I'm sorry you you'll be
next Miss St
Clair you're all great thank
you good morning uh Mr chairman members
of the labor committee thank you for
allowing me to testify my name is Karen
Leo Hill I am a 19-year city councelor
in Lebanon the former mayor and I'm also
uh the county treasur Grafton County
Treasurer I'll be brief uh I have
testified in fact Facebook reminded me
of a memory of I think testifying in
2011 against Right to Work legislation
in New Hampshire it was in a much larger
venue and then you could see all the
people amassed but right to work has
been uh wrong for New Hampshire for a
long time and uh in my perspective uh as
a city counselor I sit on the other side
of labor at the bargaining table but but
uh I am here in solidarity right to work
is wrong for New Hampshire thank you all
right any questions for the
counselor seean thank you thank
stclair good morning thank you chair and
thank you to the committee for allowing
me to speak today U my name is Tracy
stclair um I am a very proud Union
member have been for 2830 years I'm
currently a field representative with
Teamsters Local 633 here in New
Hampshire I'm also a resident in Albany
New Hampshire I'm here today in
opposition of House Bill
1377 Right to Work statistics show in
states with right to work laws the
poverty rates are higher 15.3% overall
21.4% for children which is just
terrible frankly compared with poverty
rates of 12.8% overall and 18% for
children in states without these
laws again all of that is very sad we
don't need to make those things worse
additionally people under the age of 65
in states with no right to work laws are
more likely to be uninsured 133%
compared with
99.4% in free bargaining
States in our world today we can't
afford to take any actions which
contribute to higher poverty rates more
homeless families and more of our
friends and family without health
insurance with Rising costs of health
insurance and living in general New
Hampshire is ranked number 10 in the
nation for the high cost of healthare
it's not uncommon for people to lose
their homes have to file bankruptcy just
based on health care costs alone union
jobs provide excellent benefits and
health care which help take care of that
problem in and of
itself right to work is wrong because a
legislation forces Union representatives
to work for free on behalf of employ
emplo who represent uh who request Union
representation but don't pay for that
representation this representation is
not only in the event of discipline or
something along those lines but
additionally in negotiating the benefits
and wages that they also enjoy not only
the paying dues
members in New Hampshire we pride
ourselves in being the Live Free or Die
state to allow a legislative body to
make such important decisions on behalf
of residents and voters of the state is
direct conflict with those beliefs we
want to make those decisions ourselves
and leave that at a local level workers
should have the Liberty to choose by
voting whether to join a union I urge
this committee to vote itl on House Bill
much any questions for the presenter uh
Miss stclair can you tell me how many
members you have in New Hampshire and
local uh 633 roughly uh
5,400 and that's in many different
sectors uh we
represent public sector as well as
private sector so it's many many
different
careers all right thank you very much
thank you is is a is there a mic key
y King sure could be
king say where they're from uh it
seven ladies and gentlemen my name is
Mike King I'm a local 7 iron worker
since September of 2000 thank you for
having me want to thank everybody in the
room for your attention today in this
very serious
matter uh Right to Work diminishes the
prosperity of the
masses okay prosperity in the website
dictionary is defined as economic
well-being health wealth
Hampshire is known for okay
uh as far
as quality of life in New Hampshire New
Hampshire is one of the highest states
with the highest quality of life okay
peace of
mind okay the crime rate in New
Hampshire is the lowest in the country
in Nashville New Hampshire out of 10,000
City towns and villages in this great
country that we live in Nash New
Hampshire has the lowest crime rate in
the
country New Hampshire number one state
to retire in most desirable state to
retire in in is in the United States of
America New Hampshire quality of life is
off the
charts excuse me okay
um the safest states to live in America
the number one is uh New Hampshire
number two is Maine number three is
Vermont okay out of the top 100 cities
in America that is safe
40% of them are in the Northeast
Corridor now why is
that okay that has to do with Union
density because unions offer great jobs
great paying jobs great benefits Health
Care
retirements life the ideal life is set
up with 25 years of learning 40 Years of
earning and the rest for
yearning okay now we all strive to get
to that yearning stage that's our goal
now when you work for a union compared
to a right to work
business there's a part of gold there at
the end of the tunnel for
you because when you retire you need
need
resources okay according to the Vanguard
group December of last year a couple of
months ago the average American retires
with
401K folks we all live okay with
hamburger at $8 a pound I was I worked
in a meat locker for 42 years 20
fulltime 22 part-time while I did Iron
work for 22
years $8 a pound for
hamburger that's 50 cents an
ounce you know what your ounce of
hamburger is it's a
pinch okay a Loa of bread is
$3 okay a doesn't exit
350 that's not a part of gold folks that
the right to work is going to give you
and the end to afford
that okay
that's a can of
soup
okay
now right to
work there's only one part of gold and
that's going to go to the
owner okay now when you work for a union
you have great benefits as I said
earlier you have health care you have
annuity you have a pension these things
all
matter so not only does the owner have a
part of goal but the employee does
too and that's what matters I bought a
house in New Hampshire Manchester New
Hampshire in uh March of
2003 for the very fact that I knew that
New Hampshire was high in quality of
life and it brought me great peace of
mind now that stuff is
priceless
okay we're asking that you don't give
this away to just one
person that
you shoot this right to work a general
way okay promote the unionism in this
state give people dignity when they
retire that's what's in that part of
goal dignity
respect okay they're not going to get
that with right to work the owner is
going to get
it but the masses need
it folks I thank you for your time and I
hope that I was able to deter your
thoughts about even putting this forth
forward thank you very much for your
time thank you there any questions for
the
presenter have
question I mean I'll be more than have
answer any questions we're all set thank
you sure sir okay you did a very good
job sir thank you than you very
much another one learning yearning
learning earning and yearning thank you
633 thank
you good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Scott Gove I'm a current recording
Secretary of Teamsters Local 633 of
Manchester New Hampshire I'm here today
in opposition of House Bill 1377 Right
to Work according to New Hampshire
Department of Labor New Hampshire High
Cost of housing and utilities are major
factors in corporate relocation
decisions and not New Hampshire's right
to work status right to work is wrong
because the legislation forces Union
representatives to work for free on
behalf of employees who request Union
representation but won't pay for that
representation Right to Work legislation
allows employers to keep wages lower
benefits scarcer and in some cases abuse
is quiet it benefits employers whose
goals are to keep employees divided and
distracted right to work is wrong and is
not needed in New Hampshire it is
fundamentally
unamerican in New Hampshire we have a
2.3% unemployment with over 177,000 job
openings
available workers should have the
Liberty to choose by voting whether to
join a union I urge this committee to
vote itl and House Bill
1377 thank you on a more personal note
I've worked in this community in New
Hampshire for 36 years delivering
packages probably to many of your
homes I've raised three
children with the wages and
benefits of my union along with my
brothers and sisters that sit behind me
and also out in the
hall one is graduating with an
electrical engineering degree from the
University of New Hampshire the other is
the seconde student at Keen
State without the ability and the pay
and the benefits and the retir
retirement benefits that that the union
has provided my family I don't know if
my children would have that ability and
that I would have those resources to
help them go to school and get a a
further further
education again I urge you to write uh
vote itl and I thank you for your time
and we'll take any questions thank you
any questions for the
presenter being done thank you very
much
McCain
work yeah did I butcher your name you
know closer than most
people it's tough name McCain beter is
how I pronounce it
but dealer's
Choice all right Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is McCain Baker
and I'm the executive director of New
England citizens for right to work here
to speak in support of House Bill 1377
and the freedom of Association that it
advances spill would protect workers
from being compelled to pay Union doer
fees without their consent in order to
work for a living finally making New
Hampshire right to work state
unfortunately under current law Union
boss can claim Monopoly bargaining power
over dissenting workers taking away the
individual's right to negotiate for
themsel the union boss then demands the
government enforced authority to extract
mandatory dues or fees from that
unwilling worker adding insult to injury
this poll show the vast majority of
Voters agree it's just plain wrong this
bill would guarantee workers the right
to decide for themselves whether or not
a labor union deserves their financial
support same as any other private
organization once when asked if you
would support a controversial resolution
at a national Union convention former
iosa State Education Association
executive director Fred comr said hell
no we don't support it I was a right to
work state we have to earn our
membership if we supported that we'd
lose too many
members you see without Right to Work
protections there's little incentive for
Union officials to offer a good service
to their members they can compel people
to pay them either way fact is good
unions don't need forc dues and bad
unions don't deserve them furthermore
it's clear that right to work would help
Hampshire's economic Outlook
2012 to 2022 the number of people
employed grew by 6.7% in New Hampshire
8.6% in all such Forest unionism States
right to work states on the other hand
enjoyed employment growth of
15.7% more than double hours and that's
no surprise because area development
magazine surveys have consistently found
anywhere from 50 to 80% of Business
Leaders and site selection Consultants
consider State's right to work status
either important or very important to
their decision decisions furthermore
Merit data reveals residents of right to
work states enjoy roughly
$2,600 more an average cost of living
adjusted disposable income per person
per year that's more than 10,000 in
purchasing power for a family of four
clearly not only is Right to Work the
morally right thing to do protecting
this Freedom will also help New
Hampshire workers and the New Hampshire
economy therefore on behalf of our tens
of thousands of members and supporters
across the state I urge the committee of
support house bill 1377 thank you thank
presenter
conquered
conquered um follow
so you said uh people are paying dues
without consent I've been paying dues
for 28 years because I want to because
not because I'm forced to I don't
understand you get the without consent
part uh I'm not saying that everybody
pays dues without
consent well you kind of did because you
didn't say some people do all right
question let him no it's all right it's
all right represent he's going to answer
I'll let you ask other questions all
right my apologies sir that's not a
common sense understanding of the
English language and just because one
person does one thing doesn't mean that
everybody else is uniform in that
behavior there are people that
are compelled to pay dues to keep their
job or get their job uh because New
Hampshire is not a right to work state
they would not join the union or pay the
union a dime if they had the choice but
because of current law in New Hampshire
payments there a followup representative
cler there's a lot of followup but
um I'm not sure where to start to be
honest and
uh um it's probably a conversation that
would last longer than we' all we'd all
like why don't you give it two think of
your two good questions or your two best
questions and then if you'd like to
speak with the presenter outside you can
do that I appreciate that thank you and
thank you as well you know um Force
unionism what's
that it would be the concept that some
workers are forced to pay union dues in
order to get or keep their jobs so the
unionism would be the association with
the Union the force part would be that
it's involuntary it's a matter of labor
law because nature is not a right to
work
state
right again I just
uh I I just don't want to battle right
here as much as I'd like to but um I
don't know like I like I said you know
if we if we want to chat on a different
level we can definitely do that but um
for the sake of time and for the sake of
everybody here I'm not going to go too
crazy so thank you thank you appreciate
you thank you any other questions for
the
presenter represent McKenzie so are you
familiar with the national lior
Relations Act I am okay so so isn't it
illegal under that under the national uh
Labor Relations Act to force somebody to
be a union member it's it's legal
law so it is not illegal to force people
to associate with the Union it is
allowed under the National Labor
Elations act unless States opt out under
section 14b of the tap tartle act which
amended the National Labor Relations Act
by passing a state right to work law in
States like New
Hampshire unions are perfectly able to
force workers to associate with
them followup
questions
so but that's your understanding of the
National Labor Relations Act that that
members can be compelled to be in a
union in spite of the fact that that
would be illegal in the United States
already been decided but your opinion is
they can be forced in New Hampshire
Webster's Dictionary defines join join
Union as to associate oneself with
certainly any worker compelled to
provide material support for an
organization is inherently compelled to
associate with it funding an
organization is the deepest form of
Association Force unionism violates
individual workers freedom of
Association whether or not the union
lists them on official membership roles
or lets some vote on internal affairs
and sometimes union bosses will distort
the facts even further consider
carefully this quote from Article 2
Section one of the United Auto Workers
New National cont contract employees
covered by this agreement at the time it
becomes effective and to are members of
the Union at that time shall be required
as a condition of continued employment
to continue membership in the union for
the duration of this agreement employees
covered by this agreement who are not
members at this time this agreement
becomes effective shall be required as a
condition of continued employment to
become members of the Union perhaps the
UAW is being frank here and their
practices fall short what's permissible
under current law or perhaps UW simply
trying to mislead workers strong arming
them into submission either way right to
work allow would help Shield grain
Injustice I would the only thing Mr
chairman is that I would like to see the
source of that and the whether or not
that's an interpretation that's being
Advanced here again it would be a
violation of the National Labor
Relations Act to force somebody to be a
union member thank you Mr CH if you have
if the presenter has any kind of uh
information that he can provide to the
chair I would appreciate that to get
that to the committee sure it's Article
2 Section one of the United aut workers
New National contract and that's a
direct quote from the contract thank you
representative
love point of order and that's the
people out in the hall that was my next
thing if some gentleman toward the end
would ask people uh in the hallway to be
a little quiet I don't want to close the
door because it's winter and some people
are sick and I don't want it to get too
hot in here here and I have the window
open so we got some fresh air so um
thank you um thank you for presenting uh
any other questions see n uh next I I
don't testimony he has it written in a
way that he can give to us if you have
any written testimony we'd be uh uh
happy to take it for the committee
there's no name on this uh it is the New
Hampshire Jewish clergy it says multiple
Jewish faith leaders Statewide there's
no name is there um yeah can somebody
just shout in the hallway to see if a
Jewish clergy representative is there if
not they asked that their testimony be
entered this is today's card so I would
here the next is going to be Reverend uh
next so if the uh anyone from the Jewish
clergy comes in I will get them next
okay well honorable chairman and members
of the committee my name is Gail Kenny
and I reside in Kanan New Hampshire um
I'm speaking today on behalf of the
economic Justice team of the New
Hampshire United Church of Christ which
is the UCC the largest Protestant
denomination in New Hampshire um you may
be more familiar with uccc as the
congregational churches and um our
tradition and multiple Faith Traditions
across the state um have been telling uh
this Committee in this legislature for
years or decades that um they vigorously
oppose um the deceptively labeled um law
right to work right to work bills
whenever they have been introduced um
the Jew I I I want to add just the
Jewish clergy um Association in New
Hampshire has asked that their testimony
be entered so I'm going to since they're
not outside right now or haven't
presented I'm going to do that at the
end of my testimony just enter the
testimony um I also just as an aside um
I've we've heard several times now the
reference to union bosses I am a long
time Church Pastor I am also a proud
Union member and uh formerly I was the
national Secretary treasur of my union
and okay what does a union Boss look
like to you do I look like a union boss
so just want to say that Reverend Dr
Gail Kenny the union boss um so um our
faith leads us to understand that
workers deserve to have a voice on the
job and the right to come together
collectively we also believe that New
Hampshire employers with unions have a
right to negotiate their with their
workers without the heavy hand of the
legislature telling them what specific
contractual decisions can can or cannot
be in the contract that employers choose
willingly to negotiate with their
workers um so if the outof state
Architects representative of the
national Right to Work committee through
the name New England right to work
committee and other National architects
of this bill came to you bearing truth
as opposed to false witness they would
tell you where Right to Work came from
and I hope uh you know by now but just
in case you don't just a real um quick
history in the 1940s in the Jim Crow
South workers in the textile industry
and other places in the South decided to
come together collectively to organize
collectively to have a voice on the job
and to negotiate over wages benefits and
working conditions black workers and
white workers in the South came together
and began to form unions oh no how can
that possibly be happening in the Jim
Crow South so powerful
industrialist um led by a gentleman
named Vance muse from Texas got together
and said how can we stop this and they
dreamed up the concept of right to work
what they called right to work they
thought it was a great name that they
invented but the concept was to enter
into law made it um to
prohibit in law um any kind of
contractual um provision that said that
all workers who were represented by the
union black workers and white workers
should contribute to the cost of
contract negotiations not anything else
contract
negotiations and they felt specifically
that if they could do this and say to
White workers you don't have to pay your
union dues because we've passed a law in
the state that you don't have to do that
anymore and encourage white workers not
to pay union dues that would completely
eviscerate the collective power of the
Union in that particular workplace and
just so um Vance Muse um who was leading
this effort all across the South um from
Texas to the Atlantic Ocean um he also
went before a US Senate hearing to talk
about the value of these new laws that
he had dreamed up and he said to the US
Senate um in hearing I'm a southerner
and a white supremacist and this is the
way to go and then in his literature he
also
said this is what right to work is okay
his literature promoting right to work
laws said that if right to work laws
were not passed and then this is a quote
here if right to work laws are not
passed white women and white men will be
forced into organizations meaning unions
with black African Apes whom they will
have to call brother or lose their jobs
that is the origin of Right to Work its
sole purpose is to divide workers on the
job that remains its sole purpose today
um just really quickly we heard
Fantastical previous testimony uh in
January from one of the sponsors of the
bill who painted a picture and said what
if the New Hampshire AFL C and Walmart
got together in cahoots and forced every
Walmart worker um to become a union
member that's what would happen if we
don't pass right to work laws that is so
Far From Reality coming from a sponsor
it's scary um
so unionized workers already have a
freedom to vote democratically on
whether or not they want a clause in
their contract calling for all workers
to share modestly in the cost of
representation and contract
Administration New Hampshire employers
have the right to choose whether or not
to have such a clause in their contract
that addresses workers sharing the
modest cost
representation I don't know why um
non-union employers are coming before
you pleading for this because every
non-union employer or frankly every
unionized employer in this state already
has a choice as to whether or not to
accept a certain provision in their
contract it's their choice it shouldn't
be your choice in the Live Free or Die
State um New Hampshire workers have a
freedom to choose whether or not to seek
employment in any place where they're
already exist a democratically um you
know organized Union um it's already
legally established that no worker can
be forced to be a union member and that
the freedom and the process already
exists to seek seek relief even from
Modest sharing in the cost of Union
representation and I want to say
something about construction
construction contractors have the
freedom to choose whether or not to
enter into Partnerships with their
construction unions so that the union
not the employer the Union Bears the
major responsibility for employee
screening and training in a way that
makes those contractors those employers
more productive and competitive if you
prohibit these agreements in the state
of New Hampshire how is this legislature
going to compensate those employers and
make them
whole so um one thing the at the last
hearing one of the proponents of um the
right to work Bill said in the hearing
and I don't know if it was captured in
the microphone or whether it was just an
aside that he said afterwards but what
he said is he kind of turned to the side
and he said he sort of looked at
committee this committee members and
said why don't you just vote 10 to 10
and be done with it and the message to
me about that is that nobody is
listening nobody is listening to the
employers that have come before you and
said don't do this to this just vote the
way you've always voted and and you know
never mind the testimony so with that I
implore you don't be manip ated by the
false witness that comes before you on
this bill please just vote in expedient
to legislate and please listen to the
testimony um I want to enter into the
record the um Jewish clergy I just want
to read that um the leaders of the
Jewish clergy in New Hampshire um uh
Rabbi Dan Aronson from ke Rabbi Beth
Davidson from Manchester canor Marana
firstman from Bartlett Rabbi Jan Catz
from lonia Rabbi Donna kers bomb
Bethlehem Rabbi Peter Levy of dairy
caner Amy Brena mitz of Sugar Hill Rabbi
Robin nashy of conquered caner Shir
nashy of conquered Rabbi Mark philppe of
Manchester Rabbi Joshua seagull of
Bennington caner Wendy Sherman of
Guilford and Rabbi K Stern Kaufman of
Portsmouth have all collectively put in
a statement saying explaining in some
detail their religious tradition the
Jewish religious tradition and why right
to work in the state of New Hampshire is
wrong morally and they too are asking in
expedient to legislate so I enter their
testimony thank you thank you
representative
lir thank you Mr chair and thanks for
your testimony when you were a union
boss did you force all your people to
pay you or or to join and did you use
that money for big vacations and and
things like
that absolutely not our members wanted
very much to be a part of the Union so
that collectively they could have a
voice on the job it was something that
people aspired to which is why the
workers came to together collectively to
form the union to begin with no forcing
involved thank you thank you Mr chair
thank you other
questions seeing none thank you very
much representative I know you need to
get back to your committee
representative
wheeler I appreciate that Mr chair
members of the committee thank you for
your time I will be extraordinary fairly
brief as you have many people here who
will say the same things that I will and
I just wanted to affirm for the people
of Peter bro the union workers that I
have in my town that right to work is
wrong for New Hampshire I don't support
it the union workers here don't support
it unions are important because workers
when they are individually working with
their boss don't have any power and what
unions need is that collective
bargaining to allow themselves to have
that power with their employer to be
able to make decent wages to be able to
get vacation hours to be able to work
more uh for the for their dollar people
deserve to be able to work one job and
meet their wages and what's happening
right now in the United States I know it
because I'm living it right now I I get
the privilege of being a legislator but
I have to be busy busy busy to make sure
that the bills are made people are
underwater and they need unions to be
able to get them out of that to be able
to work collectively in order to move
forward and unions have built what we
see here today they're the reason we
have the weekend they're the reason we
have any labor protection that we have
right now and I think supporting the
unions is an important thing and I'm
here against right to work so thank you
Mr chairman for your time and I will get
back to my committee any questions for
the representative as he scoots thank
you very
much David Kaza he was at a pink card
from previous hearing CA za Dennis sorry
Dennis he's um not here today okay yeah
Rick
lton from tacher
6303 who was okay that's too
bad Karen
yeah okay good morning my name is Karen
Irwin and thank you for this opportunity
chairman and members of the committee to
speak to you in opposition I'm speaking
in opposition to House Bill 1377 and I
hope you all join me and making uh
making a motion for this bill to be an
expedient to legislature uh legislate
I've spoken before on this bill and um I
wanted to let you know that um there are
a lot that's already encapsulated that
this bill seems to go after that's
already encapsulated in federal and
state legislation the first
is I I am a
um uh former employee of the State of
New Hampshire and I am a member of the
SEIU um I've been a
longterm before I retired and I'm a
current retiree member of the Union um
long time I worked for the state for 34
years and been a member of that of that
Union for that time I've worked with
that Union in a lot of ways I've been um
I'm chairman of the conservative
committee right now I still am chairman
of that committee I um even though I'm
retired I was a part of the collective
bargaining team and I was in a year that
it was it was tough Financial Times and
we worked with the governor you know
those that were elected to the
collective bargaining committee worked
with the governor on making sure we
preserve jobs and that we we cut medical
costs where we could and that we also
got pay increases we did that with a
survey the survey went out to people
when you are asked to join a union you
are asked um to sign a card and ask for
that money to be taken out of your
paychecks that's completely volunteer
and even after the Janice decision
happened which was June 27th
2018 which eliminated the fair share
membership requirement which seems to be
the crust of this bill um that no longer
happens
for public um
employees the state of New Hampshire
has four unions that represent um
10,27 positions in n in
20122 of those positions only
7,527 were filled and of those filled
positions SEIU represented
4,910 which were due paying members so
as you can see overwhelmingly
voluntarily people are joining unions
because they believe in the principles
it brings and the benefits it
brings so already in
legislation you know um there is that
prohibition from the right to strike is
already prohibited in state leg in the
state legislation and one thing this
bill does that is completely
unnecessary even if it was to pass for
some reason this part should definitely
come out of it which is 273
D9 which um
which h establishes a penalty section
that says any person employer labor
organization agent or representative of
an employer or labor organization who
directly or indirectly imposes upon any
person a requirement prohibit by this
chapter shall be guilty of a misdemeanor
and um you know may have a fine not
exceeding $1,000 and up to 90 days in
prison there's no definition of this I
believe the um you know
the they there is a fiscal note on this
um because they didn't know how to how
they would impose this how would you
impose it for what so please take that
out that doesn't belong in any part of
right to work in any sense of the
imagination
um the state contract that we get for
years has been has been put together and
organized by Union representation formed
together by employees joining together
have one
voice and full represent representation
and through elected
leaders the president or the union boss
is an elected leader so all of this is a
very public very well organized process
it saves the state of New Hampshire a
lot of money from you know having a
negotiated contract that everybody comes
to the table and having a process where
contract infractions are are go through
committees and and do everything and so
I
re respectfully request that any Bill
consider that New Hampshire workers
through being here and other things have
already demonstrated their worker rights
through their voluntary membership of
the many labor unions of the State of
New Hampshire and that this house bill
37 1377 is not a new Hampshire worker
priority please join me in in voting
this
it I'll be Happ
questions seeing none thank you very
much is there a representative
Joe
you thank you Mr chairman Joe Guthrie
for the record I represent at
Hamstead uh and I'm here mainly
because I'm get concerned when we see
the bills over and over again quite sure
you you have more
information than then then you really
need to make a decision and I I just
want to put a face on someone who votes
against bills like
this uh I have voted against them I'm
one of the few that voted against a bill
similar to this at the last time that uh
was very controversial so I would just
like to tell you that my experience and
I'm the oldest member of the house uh
and I see a lot of white hairs and I
hope that that says to me that you have
the same kind of life experience that I
may have had and I came to uh as a Young
Man uh in a union uh was just beginning
and we had such a thing as
scaps I don't even know if anybody knows
what that word means anywhere it
happened to be people who didn't want to
pay their way didn't want to pay their
dues and in those days the union needed
as much protection as they could have
and I think they still need that
protection and I I'm sorry to see that
there is a move that uh
uh is doing what some anything to weaken
the relationship between labor and the
union and I would suggest to you that
that relationship is stronger and better
when everybody
participates and uh pays their way well
I don't really have any questions but I
will answer them but that's I just
wanted to put a face on someone who at
least has has gone through what the
union went through uh getting organized
and uh but that was a different
situation I'd hate to see that go back
we resurrect the word scab thank you for
your attention any questions for the
representative San thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman is there a
Nicholas Leiden
Perez I just want some props here good
job good
job good morning Mr Leiden ibw
welcome chair committee thank you for
taking tons of testimony um I know was a
little bit more than you guys usually
get um I'll try to talk about things
that haven't already been talked about
um I wanted to give a little bit of my
personal experience with unions uh I'm a
union electrician unlike a lot of the
people that have spoken today I'm not a
lifelong Union member I did 18 years out
of the Union working privately um was
never bothered I was never forced to go
and work in a union until actually the
first interaction I had with the Union
was when I decided that I wanted to join
a union because I wanted the retirement
benefits that came with it so I know the
the big thing that has been said in uh
the positive towards this bill is that
it's to protect workers from being
harassed by unions I worked 18 years for
some of the biggest non-union
contractors I never got approached by
unions ever got harassed to become a
part of a union like I said the first
time that I ever spoke with a union rep
to become a union member was when I
decided that I wanted to be
um I understand what they're saying with
um if the unions offer a great
product then people will want to be
union members we all appreciate the
roads we appreciate the firefighters but
if taxes were opt in absolutely no one
would opt in we know that that's that's
human nature um so to rely on people to
opt in if it's a great business model
and the government switch to it be
bankrupt within a real short amount of
time because again it's just not in
human nature to opt into things like
that even though we like the services
that they provide
so even some of our members that enjoy
the services that are being offered they
may not opt in and uh in the state right
now we're Electrical Workers inside
construction we build buildings we have
a deficit of Electrical Workers right
now and we operate a multi-million
dollar training facility that was all
privately paid for and privately funded
so we are providing electricians to the
state of New Hampshire never taken a
dime of tax money for that we haven't
taken a tax break that's all paid for by
our members contributing to that and our
contractors contributing um like I said
I want to try and keep my testimony
pretty short because I know there's a
lot of people that want to speak I'll
has Madam
clerk thank you Mr chair um forgive me
if you said this but doesn't your union
also as a benefit to future members and
current members and the recruitment of a
very important aspect of our economy
have a training academy too a training
facility yes we have a training facility
it was built in 2008 and it cost $1.3
million to build um we don't we charge
our students that come into our apprenti
ship $200 that's it um it costs us about
$2,800 just in the books per student
that's all paid for by the members
contributing to the education of our
future electricians and again this is
this is an education that we provide
without taking any money from the
government to train electricians to work
state all right thank you very much for
your testimony oh I'm sorry one more
question representative
love thank you for taking my question
thank you Mr chair um I've heard a lot
where you know uh unions complain that
uh non-paying um employees are
benefiting from collective bargaining
and all the benefits and have the unions
ever thought about going to the the
federal delegation where the where the
pro problem actually exists as far as
that goes uh to to remove that from
National Labor Relations Bo U uh
statutes to uh to to make it so if uh if
I'm not paying you don't have to serve
me to my knowledge no um we have
obviously Internationals uh that serve
in DC and speak to that for the most
part though our unions in the Building
Trades all kind of operate autonomously
we're kind of our own government we're
set up much like you guys are so as far
as like as far as bargaining for your
own uh benefits and your own wages the
other thing to keep in mind is we only
set minimums so we don't set speed
limits we don't set the cap we have a
lot of members that make well over what
the basic requirements are alls we set
with our CBA is this is the least that
you can pay someone but it's not the
most you can pay someone we have plenty
of people that have negotiated for
themselves above and beyond the Union
contract um most of our general foremen
and our foremen who are overseeing the
bigger jobs like lonz of pharmaceuticals
and some of the bigger construction
projects in the state they get paid well
over what our our minimum CBA is that's
just that's the basic of what you can
offer but you can always negotiate with
your contractor if you're worth more to
get more than what the CBA is you're not
limited in that sense
um follow
up my uh my question was basically um
you know the the fact that unions
complain that you know there's there's
Free Loaders okay I don't like that
either I don't I don't think I should be
getting uh I should be able to mark walk
walk into Market Basket and grab a half
a dozen stakes and walk out okay it's
not right and that's essentially what
happens when there's somebody reloading
on the union okay my question is have
the
unions you know gone to the federal
delegation with the problem that's the
Crux of the problem as far as that
problem goes uh you know uh i' I'd like
to see it change myself and uh and it'll
take the unions to to do it and uh you
know it's not whether you you know
somebody can re renegotiate their wages
or anything um but um you know uh has
has it ever happened
is
to my knowledge no um if sorry if I
understand your your question correctly
you're asking if we've ever gone and
confronted like our International
offices about what they're
doing no the federal delegation I'm
sorry sorry I didn't understand senators
and and Congressman uh no to my to my
knowledge I know that we have lobbyists
and stuff up in DC like everyone does
but as far as what they're actively
involved in we don't really stay on top
of it that's kind of why we pay them so
as just a business agent in New
Hampshire I I try to focus on just
what's going on in the state because as
you can see there's plenty for us to
focus on just right
here thank you would you have any idea
why all right all right thank you for
sorry David I'm gonna representative
he's not GNA be able to answer the
question thank you very much for your
testimony I'm sorry representative kill
I'll stay Thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question this probably
isn't really an issue for you but do you
have any idea how long it takes to find
an electrician to come to your house and
th
something uh yeah pretty long time um
there's there's a lot of Labor shortages
right now in state um
we're we're not um devoid of that we
have issues too even trying to bring
kids into the program uh we can usually
take in about 20 to 40 depending upon
whether we split the class up we
struggle sometimes to get enough to fill
those classes and even when we have
hiring sprees where we're looking for
more workers everyone that wants a job
is working so there's there's very few
people that are out of work right now so
yeah I I know it's extremely difficult
to get any trade especially electricians
to come to work right now thank you
especially your house Michael all right
thank you very much for your
testimony all right representative Perez
here good morning thank you for allowing
me to speak my name is Maria Perez and
I'm a state representative from District
43 in Milford I'm here to ask the
committee to ital this bill this is a
bill that is coming over and over again
as someone who um it was a a union
member back in the days when I work for
H senator Amy kashar let me tell you
being a union member it was the best
thing that happened to me as an
organizer forred uh a
senator just to give you a little bit of
brief background when you work as an
organizer you get paid salary you're
supposed to work 40 hours but at the end
of the day you work seven days a week
sometime 80 to 100 hours a
week and after we we got signed into a
contract and then we uh come part of the
Union everything change our rise change
the way that we work in we didn't work
seven days a week anymore we were
allowed to have days
off we have sick time and we have more
benefits than before that we come in
part of the Union my husband he's an
electrician here in New
Hampshire and then my son he's an
electrician in North Carolina and to be
honest what what we seeing in the trade
is like we need more people in the trade
we keep telling kids to get in debt to
go to college and then be $200 to
$300 $300,000 in dead and a lot of these
kids don't even get a job in they what
they went to school for and they ended
up going to a trade school why we don't
push more for people to be in the trades
because that's what we need the people
right now we don't have enough people
and I'm grateful that a lot of the
unions and I'm going to be saying this a
lot of these
unions have refugees legal document
people who come
here going into the trades train them
because they already have a background
in their countries and help them to make
sure they get the proper training and
they they are part of the trade here in
the US so I'm grateful to for the junion
and that's why it's saying please itl
this bill it keep coming back we don't
need it a new huni we need more workers
we need more people in the trades thank
representative see no questions thank
you very much is Sarah canoy here she
had uh pink card from last
time
David
ady I think that from last time yep it
was it's trying to trying
to we already heard from earlier today
that's right I
apologize um Reverend John Gregory
Davis followed by Deborah how if she's
here yes hello my name is Reverend John
Gregory Davis with my partner Susan I
co-pastor to the Congregational Church
in Meridan New Hampshire and am part of
the United Church of Christ that uh my
uh colleague Gail referred to as the
largest POS denomination in the state
which has consistently advocated worker
rights I want to begin by saying that I
am not now nor I have ever been part of
a union but like most of you I assume
unless any of you are independently
wealthy I work for a living and those of
us who work know what it means to be
paid well we know what it means to be
not paid well we know what it means to
take advantage of benefits that unions
have made possible for us our world and
our working conditions would be
profoundly different had unions not
organized to make sure that we had
things like a 40-hour week and 8h hour
day weekend and and uh time time off um
and we all benefit from that regardless
of whether we were part of the unions
that uh advocated for that or not and my
guess is none of us would want to live
in a world where that didn't happen now
let's be clear it didn't happen because
the employer said let's take care of our
people let's make sure that they're not
overworked it happened because unions
organized to demand what their employers
were unwilling to give the strongest
argument against against this right to
work so-called bill that strangely keeps
coming up in the state despite the fact
that New Hampshire thus far has the
distinction being one of the few states
that consistently says no and I trust
and hope we'll be we'll do that again
the strongest argument against it is
that the
proponents have so little faith in their
argument that they chose to lie and we
keep talking about we keep using their
language but their language is wrong
there's nothing about this that has
anything to do with the right to work
there's nothing about it it's it's it's
a dising genous naming misnaming of a
bill to to um skew the conversation had
they the the honesty and the Integrity
they would have called it something like
right to exploit or Right to Work For
Less because this isn't about worker
rights this is about disempowering
unions so that employers have more power
now let's also be clear that if the
unions didn't exist this bill wouldn't
be here and that's of course the goal of
this bill to to disempower unions the
whole argument about
and to go back to to your question
representative love about why why not
just uh um disengage people who don't
want to be part of the Union that's
again that's missing the issue the
reason this matters to employers and
note by the way you're going to hear
from very few if any workers that
support this the reason employers want
this is because they know that the fewer
people there are that are part of unions
they're paying dues the less power the
unions have this is about disempowering
unions it's not about a right to work
and this just be and I just want to be
clear about the conversation so that we
we understand where we're coming from
and the argument about you know uh
freeloading I mean it's the argument
used earlier was about taxes that if
people were said well you know if you
don't want to pay your taxes we you'll
still get all the benefits but why
should you have to pay taxes or if I
ride up to a toll booth and I say well I
believe in the right to drive and I I
don't feel I should have to pay the toll
these are ridiculous arguments we know
that and we ought to be quite we we're
wise enough I think to dismiss them to
name this disingenuous dishonest
fundamentally immoral bill for what it
is and to and to make it inexpedient to
legislate once again as New Hampshire
has done consistently thus far and we
are counting on you to do again this
time thank
[Applause]
testimon Deborah house followed by
Pamela e
Ian
morning okay good morning chairman
infantine and members of the labor
committee my name is Deborah house and I
am the democratically elected president
of the American Federation of teachers
New Hampshire I'm not a union boss
you're a union boss no I'm not a union
boss uh the members of our 27 locals
elected me president and I'm here to
represent them um and just to be clear
we have mostly public sector workers but
we also do have one private sector local
which is the ringe faculty Federation um
so I'm here not only on behalf of our
one private sector local but also all of
our Union brothers and sisters and uh
Union family in the private sector
because uh we are here in staunch
opposition of HB 1377 the so-called
right to work um it is and always has
been not the New Hampshire way it is an
interference in negotiation between
employers and employees as represented
by their unions we strongly stand for
the rights of workers to join together
in a union and negotiate with their
employers over wages hours and working
conditions because that's what allows
you to have reasonable working
conditions hours that allow you to do
your job and still have a life
afterwards still be able to go home to
your family and enjoy some time with
them before the end of the day before
you're totally exhausted uh it's
something that we all kind of aspire to
to be able to you know have a life
outside of work
um we
are in opposition to HB 1377 because it
represents government interference
between what private
employers and the employees can bargain
over and if those employers choose to
agree with their employees that there
should be a fee paid for the service of
negotiating and maintaining the
contract then that fee can become a
condition of employment just like the
employer can set other conditions of
employment like dress code or what the
hours are you have to report to work
this is not
unreasonable this is not something that
is somehow
unconstitutional we accept these
employment conditions when we accept a
job so for someone to conflate Du and
fees and say you're being forced to be a
member is some kind of linguistic
gymnastics that does violence to
logic and uh right to work has always
been against the New Hampshire way of
allowing
our private employers and employees to
set their own terms in negotiations the
government doesn't belong in the
negotiating room so we urge you to once
again vote itl on right to work and
that's all I have to say if there are
questions I will take them and uh I'm
not a union boss thank you uh there's a
question for you I I have to step out uh
Vice chairman seaworth will take over
for a moment representative McKenzie yes
representative McKenzie thank you uh and
thank you for coming uh president
house are you familiar with the
provision in the
law which
allows the voting by the members on the
specific issue of the agency fee unlike
anything
else there is a are you familiar with
the part of the law that allows them to
petition a third of the people in the
company
competition and vote specifically on
that issue are you familiar with that
provision I would have to say that I
being in the public sector where the
Supreme Court has taken this away from
the public sector I am not as familiar
with this as you are so um you will be
giving me uh more information that than
I have at this
point
uh yeah thank you you're welcome didn't
mean to put no that's that's okay um
yeah I I could certainly check with
reliable sources and and get uh
information to you on that any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony um next
up I would call Pamela Ian speaking for
herself in support of the bill and
following that Joshua
here and you need this thank you Mr Vice
chair and committee members my name is
Pamela Ian a resident of conquer New
Hampshire and I speak strongly in favor
of this
bill this bill represents our MTO Live
Free or Die everybody should have the
right to decide what to do everybody
knows the best to do for their own
family I'm a former police officer and
I'm also a retired teacher I've never
joined a union I've never been on the do
government Dole and I take issue to a
previous speaker who made it sound like
anyone who's not in the Union uh is on
the government toll that's not true and
also I was able to save money to help my
two sons get through
college now this bill addresses freedom
of
Association we have the right to
associate with whomever we please we
also have the right not to
associate this bill will help to hold
unions accountable I heard one speaker
say that union membership has
dropped well part of that reason is
because people don't feel that they're
being represented so they they don't opt
to join
union now the ageny fee is something
that um I haven't really heard too much
about here the ageny fee is what I took
issue with when I was a teacher I had
been teaching for 10 years and as
representative McKenzie said the
teachers decided in the union to vote
that everyone must pay an agency fee so
I was already employed and I had been
there for 10 years and the union bosses
came to me and said you will now pay a
fee first of all that to me is very
unamerican nobody should be forcing me
to pay money I don't wish to pay so what
I did was I did win a religious
exemption but then ironically I was told
by one of the Union lawyers you can't
give your money to St Vincent to Paul
which is a religious organization I win
because it's a religious objection that
I have to the union and yet they're
telling me I can't give my 400 some more
dollars which to me was not just a
little bit that was a
lot and I ended up having to give to a
different
charity now I was a police officer in
Texas and I know I've heard people say
that if we do away with collective
bargaining which this bill does not
address it is not saying unions can't
exist and people can't choose to join
join them and I have to say I wonder why
unions are so afraid of right to work
because all it's doing is saying that
people don't need to join and I was a
police officer in Texas we did not have
a union and there was never any problem
when contract negotiations came up so to
say that oh if you get rid of the uh
collective bargaining there's going to
be uh chaos that's not true at least I
now I've heard previous speakers say
that this
bill empowers more government but I've
also heard other people talk about the
federal government and what they have
done the federal government is the cause
of this if it wasn't for what the
federal government said we wouldn't need
right to work because people could
negotiate their own contracts or they
could get together with like-minded
people and do it without having to pay
does to do it and as I said in Texas we
never had to do that we never had to pay
someone to go to the city council and
negotiate our
contract I've heard someone say that
this bill comes up year after year after
year after year Well if anybody's seen
the movie Amazing Grace yes it is a
movie but it is based on
truth um William Wilberforce brought up
for 24 years to get rid of slavery
before it was accepted so if this bill
keeps coming up maybe it's something
that people have to start thinking about
and as far as the weekends go the
weekends were actually started by the
good Lord whether you're Jewish and it's
on the Sabbath or Christian it's Sunday
seven six days of work one day of peace
started oh and also this bill will um
hold unions more accountable because
people will either want to join or not
depending on their situation thank you
questions representative lir thank you
thank you for your testimony too thanks
for coming in and speaking
um so initially you're a lot of the
stuff you said was kind of almost for
unions as opposed to being against them
because you're you know you were going
back and forth kind of and that and
that's okay because there's uh a lot of
things on both sides that can be worked
out but my question is do you think that
unions are afraid of right to work or
right to work is afraid of unions I
think seeing all the people in this room
that have come out for unions and in
other testimonies that I've given in the
years the unions are afraid of right to
work and I don't understand that because
it's not against the union it's just
giving me as an individual or or you as
an individual the right to decide and
that is what being an American is yeah
and I I agree with you if I could follow
up please um yeah the right to decide is
is definitely everybody's right I agree
with you I worked non-un and like other
people here started off nonunion and
then went because they wanted to so um I
guess that's more of a statement than a
question but again thanks for your
testimon you're welcome sir are there
further questions representative
Sullivan
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um earlier you said that uh
the agency fee that you were expected to
um pay um as a teacher was um created by
the union um was it created by the union
or was it created by an agreement
between the union and the school board
it was probably the latter
um the members of the Union after 10
years they did vote that anyone who was
not in the Union would be forced to pay
this agency fee so unfortunately that
put me at odds with my fellow workers
because they voted to take money from me
after 10
years follow up but
again was the union able to do that on
their own or did they do that along with
an agreement with the school board who
is the employer right it was definitely
an agreement with the school board but
it wasn't something that I signed up for
when I first became a teacher there and
even though it it was an agreement it's
still wrong I mean there are lots of
things that government does agreements
that are wrong and whether it's from
years ago or now we see
that the thing is I'm an individual and
I was always taught to fight my own
battles and that's the way I am and if I
have a problem I will address it to
whomever whether it's an employee
any further questions representative
McKenzie thank
you are you familiar with the Janice
Deion yes I am it's for private I mean
uh public employees only so after 2018 I
did not have to pay in
anymore
follow during the course of your career
when you were covered by Collective
did you take the benefits that were
negotiated yeah I had to had no choice
you had to yeah so you took the I
couldn't say to my boss I don't want to
be paid this
amount F the
PO so the union negotiated the
benefits there was a
contract and you were covered by that
contract and you took all the benefits
and enjoyed all of the the um coverage
that every other person in that ban unit
received I earned the benefits and I
earned
whatever and again it's the federal
government that set up this problem to
begin with and two wrongs don't make a
right so I think what representative
love said is is very valid that the
union needs to get to address the
federal government and get rid of the
collective bargaining because no it
isn't fair that I can be represented by
something that I don't pay for but on
the other hand it's not fair for them to
either any further
questions thank you very much for your
testimony you're
welcome next up is uh Josh reap followed
here
good morning thank you for the
opportunity to be here and before I get
my testimony I just want to say I know
this is a very long hearing and I got to
say it's a testament to the people of
New Hampshire that we could be civil and
it but yet in a in a situation that's a
very polarized world it's really great
to see so many people with different
opinions remaining civil and respectful
and hearing from each other so um I hope
that we can meet an example for the rest
of the country in that regard uh but any
rate um my name is Joshua reap I'm the
president CEO of associated builders and
contractors uh we represent nearly 300
construction firms and Associated
businesses across New Hampshire our
association believes in the free
enterprise system is fundamental to Our
Success is the American way of life we
believe that the employer must have a
concern for the general welfare of the
employee and that there must be fair
compensation for that work performed at
the same time we believe that employees
have an obligation for satisfactory
performance of work assigned We Believe
leg legislation that Embraces fair play
for employer employees is essential for
the preservation of our free enterprise
system and today I'm here in support of
HP
1377 which actually would provide the
private sector with the same rights
already enjoyed by the public sector and
Workforce we believe uh that any law
that's passed should protect the rights
of employees for for work regardless of
race color creed age sex national origin
or membership or non-membership in an
organization We Believe work opportuni
should be made available to all legal
residents and we support programs toward
that end we support Right to Work simply
because um laws like this guarantee
workers can seek employment without fear
that they'd be required to join or pay
fees Associated for a union when they
are hired these laws simply allow
workers who do not want to participate
in a collective barging agreement to opt
out of joining the union or paying dues
or fees associated with that if all or
most of the members of a bargaining unit
believe a union representation will
represent their interests then nothing
in a right to work law such as one per
you would prohibit them from exercising
their federally protected right to
organize a union and bargain with their
employer however in a right to work
environment what changes is people are
liberated from the violence coercion
intimidation and peer pressure that
ultimately comes as part of unionization
in campaigns and close closed shop
states such as New Hampshire at the same
time you underneath right to work laws
as we've seen in the public sector
unions are held accountable to their
workers they have to justify their
existence they have to have a
relationship with those individuals they
just can't take for Advantage I have a
thousand people that I'm representing
and I don't need to answer everybody
under right to work everybody has a
voice everybody has a bit more power
within their organization within their
Union to have to have their voice heard
opponents state that the wages are lower
in Right to Work say States they're
entitled to their own beliefs but not
necessarily their own facts facts of the
matter today is that today's market is
an employee Market when the labor
shortages that were actually talked
about earlier across all sectors but
particularly in construction wages and
benefits are higher now than ever as
employers compete for talented labor
what opponents further fail to mention
is that the when you have a collective
bargaining agreement it takes away an
individual's right to negotiate with
their employer directly what they feel
they should be compensated for and in an
open shop world if someone feels I'm not
making what I deserve I can go somewhere
else but rather than do that I am
allowed to speak to directly to my
employer and a union collective
bargaining agreement I prohibited from
having a direct conversation with my
employer so I can't go to the owner I
can't go to my supervisor and say I want
more pay that's left up to the the union
collective bargaining
agreement so in this era where we have a
market where it is a employee um high
demand Market um individuals that are
subject to Collective bargain agreements
the employer one can't directly
negotiate with those individuals and
secondly that employer can just fall
back and say hey the CBA says I can I
only have to pay this much and that's
all I'm going to pay you so it actually
is a detriment to people in this current
labor
market um and another thing I'd like to
point out too that on Union stats.com
there's some interesting data and
information out there um when the state
P when the state became subject to the
Janice decision and union workers in the
public sector um had the choice whether
not to pay a fee or join the union they
didn't see a substantial drop in Union
membership from my my understanding from
Union .c which is publicly available
it's a website run by Trinity University
as well as Georgia University it takes
Bureau of Labor Statistics data and
analyzes it by sector um I would argue
too here in New Hampshire actually about
90% of the construction Workforce
chooses to have a direct relationship
with employer well you might say to me
well why do you want right to work then
simple um I want to make sure that
people aren't subject to the coion and
peer pressure in violence that often
times comes with not often but often not
often but sometimes with these
organization campaigns because if people
have a situation where the union has to
go in there and negotiate and justify
themselves to the individual you have a
better relationship better working
relationship between the worker and in
the Union in closing I thank thank you
for your your time and ask you support
HB 1377 for the opportunity for all
people in New Hampshire have be happy to
take any
questions representative
lir Follow by Mackenzie sure does the
ABC oh sorry thank you thanks Mike does
the ABC have a registered apprenticeship
and what does it cost um anybody that
joins to go there yep uh ABC is the only
construction trade Association across
the country it's dedicated to trade
development um we have other trade
associations that do Management training
we do that too but we also have
apprentiship programs uh and they're
they're it varies by state by state we
have one in New Hampshire we have one in
Vermont um I know the New York Chapter
has multiple trades as well um how does
it get paid for the employers pay for it
it is not it's not something the
individual pays for that's the other
thing in the open shop World um you earn
while you learn the employer pays for
the tuition more often than not now
every company can choose to do that
differently just like every country
company can negotiate with their
Collective baring agreement differently
in the union world but in our world in
my experience with my members uh the
employer pays for the training and you
it's registered right it's registered
with the state yep okay um thanks can I
follow up please yes follow up um you
said that um typically workers are
prohibited in the union from speaking to
their employers well there's a grievance
process involved with most Collective
Bain agreements will outline how to
handle grievances how to hand issues um
in my experience uh being working for an
employer that was non-union then became
unionized can I just I'm talking I'm I
apologize I should have been a little
bit more forthright about wages sure you
say they are prohibited from speaking
about wage I heard earlier that there
was testimony that someone said hey you
know this is the minim minimum that
we're going to pay you but you can talk
to your employer about possibly getting
more if you think you're more or if
you're running a job or Etc so where is
the prohibition well if you're running a
job your your pay scale changes because
your position changes if you're talking
about uh a CBA being a minimum floor
that's negotiated between the employer
and the union representation not
necessarily the individual workers on
that job site that's between the
business agent or or the representative
of the union and the employer that's not
up so if if Josh reap wants to say I
want $3 more an hour I can't just go to
the company owner and and ask him for
that I probably could try but he's going
to remind me that it's up to the I had
need to talk to my business agent and go
through the channels it's determined
it's determined by the union because
when you join a union you wave certain
rights as an individual to collectively
decide those as a group and that's where
the union steps in to represent you on
behalf of you to the employer follow up
follow up
um yeah I've been in the coer UN for 28
years I was actually a business rep for
5 years okay um when someone wants more
money or or would like more money you
know obviously they they talk to their
employer they don't come to the business
agent and say hey can I get a raise from
my company you know it's it's directly
it really is directly if if I'm wrong on
a fact I'll accept that and um you said
minimum wage so if I went to a company
if I was working for a company that
belonged to the ABC and they said well
I'm sorry all I have to give you is
minimum wage was $7.50 an
hour I don't know a single person paying
minimum wage right now that's not that
wasn't my question they could actually
say that right minimum wage is 750 I'm
all I have to give you is 750
now anyone can say whatever they want
but at the end of the day I don't have a
single contractor that's paying minimum
wage for for anything like that right
and one more question if I because at
the same time that employee can go
elsewhere yes right exactly sure and
that was going to be another one of
points but
so do you think that your wages your
wage just your hourly
wage are pretty close to what say union
carpenters
make my wages I don't I don't have any I
work for the ABC I don't you're
Carpenters I don't I don't have
Carpenters that work for the ABC
carpenters in the ABC that belong to the
ABC or or uh the Carpenters that work
for contractors that thank you for
clarifying Sor I yeah yeah it's all good
um every every company's going to be
different but I don't I don't know what
the current Carpenter Union rate is and
I can't tell you which specifically
which each contractor pays their
Carpenters but I can tell you it's going
to be competitive okay yeah okay I just
want to make sure thank you Mr chair
represent
McKenzie uh in your testimony um Mr reap
you mentioned you say this
that people are liberated from violence
coercion intimidation as frequently part
of the Union Camp unionization campaigns
can you provide this committee with any
evidence uh that uh this is happened
this has happened in New Hampshire and
in contrast to what you said when you
open your remarks commenting on how um
civil we are in New Hampshire and how
respectful we are to people in general
so can you cite any evidence to back up
that statement I'd be happy to to to
send you some links to some new
stories New Hampshire specific news sir
I I I honestly I don't I'll have to look
Hampshire U Mr re can you tell me if the
uh
ABC is uh supports Union
organizing the right of people to
self-determination and the right of
people to organize the union do you
support that does does the organization
support that
we we support people's decision to
choose for themselves whether or not
they choose to belong to or organize on
their own Mr that's Mr chairman that's
not the answer to the question that's
the answer he gave you I'm not going to
force him to answer differently and
finally one final yes
please can you describe for this
committee what your experience is in the
union environment overall you have if
you negotiate a contracts you ever
belong to a union have you been part of
a negotiating team at all uh I
personally have not been part of a
collective bargaining team or negotiated
contracts thank you
sure representative seaworth thank you
very much chairman thank you Mr chairman
um in some of the prior testimony I
heard an assertion that if an
employer doesn't feel that these these
um Fair share Agreements are appropriate
to the contract they can simply
refuse to negotiate them or to put them
in the contract do you have any
experience with that from the employer
side of of the table um there there's
been a lot of testimony can you can you
say that question again for me so
the what I heard some people say is that
if an employer doesn't think this idea
that there can there should be a fair
share of agreement that all employees
should be required to pay a certain
amount to the union that the employer
can simply say no that they don't want
that as part of the
contract do you have any experience with
that you're effectively talking about
like an agency fee or shop fee right um
that's that that fee is going to be
negotiated based on each
individual
shops agreement with the Union um I I
can't think of offhand of any situations
where there's not been a shop fee um
that that's something that often times
cvas thank you cvas colli the barting
agreements thought you said CV
sorry any other questions for the
presenter seeing none thank you very
much thank you is there a Michael
McCarthy
here he was a card from last week
or Aubrey Freeman these are two cards
meeting
yeah well we'll hold that just in case
they're they're out there uh Matthew
ibw thank you whoever's calling out
there good job thank you they get a
raise must be a union
welcome can you hear me all right um
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak to you today I come to this
discussion representing myself as a a
lifelong citizen of New Hampshire and
also a
proud Union member of ibw local 490 for
seven
years I'll keep my remarks brief I'm
speaking out against this bill it's not
what we stand for in New Hampshire we
have already discussed this previously
in the legislature numerous times in
2021 to be exact legislature voted oted
this measure down known previously as s
sp61 this has been voted down when we've
had both parties in control of
legislature this brings me to today's
hearing if this legislation was voted
down previously it
proves that no matter what side of the
aisle you're on this legislation
understands the value of unions and the
vital role that unions play in securing
jobs for the working
people this legislation does nothing for
the working people of New Hampshire it's
actually detrimental it should be named
Right to Work For
Less the average ra wage in right to
work states is an average of 8,700 less
than the same wage in non-ri to work
states like New
Hampshire a specific piece of this bill
I'd like to speak to is
273 d8 coercion and intimidation
prohibited more than seven years ago I
voluntarily walked into the IBD
ibw local 490 office looking for work I
was employed at the time I had a
job I was in the North country of New
Hampshire where I spent nine years below
the poverty level in terms of
income I was looking for change in no
way did I feel pressured or coerced to
join this
organization in fact the gentleman I
spoke to wanted to make sure I was
serious about joining as I in my mid-40s
now when was 39 years old then
I have no regrets for joining the union
do I speak to other electricians about
the Union Yes am I proud of what I am a
part of yes um this past June I was
voted in as vice president of our
Union and I'm very proud of that am I
upset when someone has no interest in
the union
no do I pressure people to join in the
conversation no I know what I have in my
hands I worked in many Industries in the
uh private and public sector since
graduating from s some college in
2001 I need to go back on something I
said I do have a regret I do not regret
a day of my education my only regret is
I did not find this opportunity in 2001
when I
graduated this bill does nothing but
Target organized labor and its policies
I'll remind you that without organized
labor historically we would not have a
40-hour work week benefits of any kind
mind protections against child labor and
the list goes on supporters of this bill
are quick to Target unions they need to
understand that with we do so much for
the good of this
country the history books only talk
about labor unions going on strike let
me be clear we do much more than
strike I am a father a brother a son and
an uncle my 9-year-old wants me to come
and visit his class to talk about what I
do for a living his teacher is very
excited about this my son is discussed
wanting to be an electrician when he
grows up I hope he'll follow in my
footsteps and joy the union but alas
it's his
choice this legislation is not good for
New Hampshire families it's good for
CEOs and
investors please vote against this Bill
thank you and I'll entertain any
questions thank you are there any
questions for the
presenter Sean thank you very much for
your
testimony I'll ask again a few cards I'd
had from either as well as today and
previously is there a Michael McCarthy
from
Bridgewater and you did say that that
leave okay I have no further pink cards
if there's anyone else who would like to
numbers
don't
supp sorry I I did I
did I don't know I gave you the one what
is your name sir uh Matthew pic Matthew
I did actually see you fill out a car
the other I was watching yeah I just
heard a I I heard a different last name
so I was a little bit
confused what is your name again sir
Pik I have a Matthew SAU he was another
gentleman you know I saw you writing it
I is there any cards up there folks that
have not come down to see me
yet sir I did see you fill it out but I
don't have one so if you would wouldn't
mind testifying then filling out another
one for me yeah I'm sorry I don't know
where it got lost testify first then
please good morning my name is Matt Pik
I'm a resident of Manchester here
representing workers democracy I've
lived in New Hampshire for 4 years and
my time here I've worked at more than a
few manufacturing jobs New Hampshire is
part of a belt of manufacturing in New
England area that represents the
backbone of American industry however
while Manufacturing in New Hampshire
employs 10% of the state's employee
Workforce the total average real wages
of its of its workers is considerably
less than our counter counterparts and
states around us why is this this is
because of the climate of vicious
harassment and antagonism that many
employers bring against workers who
exercise their legal rights as a work as
a Workforce I have personally been
involved in two separate Union campaigns
at facilities around Manchester Airport
and both times I have witnessed and have
been the victim of extensive labor
violations and unfair labor practices
including wrong wrongful terminations of
lead organizers for protected
conservative activity I'm currently on
an active nlrb case where three
voluntary organizers including myself
were fired on dubious and non-descript
charges within 4 months after our
campaign became public knowledge not to
mention the other charges uh for Brazen
acts of surveillance policy change
misrepresentation of
facts and
retaliation companies in New Hampshire
already feel that they're above the law
when dealing with Union drives and right
to work laws will only embolden them
further far too often do we speak of
unions from a business oriented or
economistic perspective but the reality
is that unions are not just a service
for working people it is in essence the
only measure by which workers can affect
effectively combat exploitation and
assert dignity at a job site unions are
organizations formed by workers
organizations that pull their forces
pull their savings pull their political
and civil activity into a United effort
because of the vast disproportional
power that corrupt wealth and Monopoly
have in this country over the past 50
years real wages have stagnated while
productivity has doubled rents have
doubled the cost of buying a home has
gone up
255 College tuitions have gone up rough
150% all adjusted for inflation and
traditional pension plans have been
nearly entirely replaced by defined
contribution or 401K plans leaving two
whole Generations without a reliable
source of income for retirement the
severe loss in buying power and the
general poor condition of our economy
can be directly correlated with the
gradual decline of union membership
which was precipitated by the passing of
the T ta heartley act establishing the
state's ability to pass Right to Work
legislation there is a likewise
correlation between the number of states
that have passed Right to Work bills and
the entropy of organized labor right to
work laws in general are only an effort
by corrupt wealth and Monopoly to break
the back of workers let us learn from
recent examples in Missouri and Michigan
where right to work was recently
defeated and reversed for the first time
in decades why were they defeated and
reversed because the American worker had
experience in knowing the truth of it
why should we join those States
dominated by corrupt wealth and Monopoly
like those in the Deep South where right
to work is an extension of right to
slave we New Hampshire rights oppose
such slave Holdings by power We Live
Free or Die and Right to Work For Less
is anything but Freedom it is a path
towards quicker death to Poverty to
continued am miseration of the worker on
the production line freedom to freeload
at the expense of others not only
freeloading in the sense of receiving
Ben benefits without putting in their
Fair contribution but also freeloading
in the sense of not contributing to the
long-term movement of organized labor
itself through the entire history
through all the energy and all of the
Blood Sweat and Tears that went into
building up our rights and building up
today if we want any chance of
recovering our economy for the working
majority and once again create a good
and widely accessible standard of living
the answer is to strengthen our unions
not weaken them the amount times this
bill has been proposed despite Mass
descent from the public and especially
from Working Families every single time
only tells me that maybe our state
delegation does not truly have the
interest of the constituency at heart
thank
you thank you for your testimony
representative kale I'm sorry mam clerk
do you have a question I just wanted to
make sure you have written testimony you
were reading from can you make sure to
send that to us certainly thank you I'm
sorry where do I send it house okay yeah
there's an online module to do that but
you can um on the page for the labor
House labor committee I'm the uh Clerk
of the committee I would include it in
the file if you just send it to me yeah
for sure thank you repr Gill thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm I'm sorry I don't I don't
think Mr Reap is still here but what you
described in early your testimony about
uh trying to trying to organize and then
being you know fired from your job and
other sort of it sounds that sounds a
bit like the coersion and intimidation
that Mr reap had in his
testimony you have a comment on
that uh I mean what I've experienced in
the course of organizing around
Manchester is that if anybody is
intimidating anyone it's the company
especially during the Union Drive and
that's what I've experienced this whole
time thank you
sir
see no other further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you very
much Larry I Mo M moai I'm sorry I'm not
French hi my name is Larry moin I'm a
resident of Bo and a member of the
laborers International Union of Norther
America local 668 in Manchester um I
wasn't going to testify but I listen to
the association of building contractors
and I would just like to bring up to you
that the association building
contractors who supports this
legislation is a membership driven
organization who requires dues and if
their members do not pay dues they will
no longer receive the services I just
wanted to make that clear to everybody
testimony there any questions for the
presenter seeing none thank you very
much I hold in my hand the final
Estelle
Claudia supposed like this I you're
ising
ourselves good morning chair infantine
and members of the committee thank you
for hearing my testimony I'm Claudia
stelle I'm a member of economic Justice
Mission group of the New Hampshire
Conference of the United Church of
Christ right to work is not good for the
workers of the State of New Hampshire
the legislature this legislation comes
to us from out of state and testimony in
the past years and this year has been
overwhelmingly against the bill for the
following reasons it is a bill that was
crafted out of state and doesn't reflect
what's happening in our state moreover
the history of the bill is racist
seeking to divide workers along race
lines and put and to put down black
workers racism is something that is not
needed in the state and is something
that we all need to take a stand on here
and across the country it is an the
anti-union anti-worker bill many workers
and many union members from a variety of
Industries have spoken about how they
have benefited from better pay better
safety better working conditions because
they are members of the Union I can say
that for myself as well they have tested
to the training opportunities that they
have received and that have helped them
gain skills to make them um workers to
of a high
standard workers testify that the
differences about differences in safety
companies and right to work states are
less diligent about safety training and
safe working conditions not only keep
workers healthy but save on cost in the
long
run workers in a right to work um States
generally earn less with half the
workers in New Hampshire earning less
than a living wage and over a quarter
stating that they have difficulty
meeting daily expenses we should be
lifting up workers moreover workers who
are respected and paid decently have
better morale which is better for their
employers too the precarious financial
situation of low wage workers leads to
food and housing insecurity poor health
and poor educational outcomes and more
need to seek Public Assistance which is
funded by taxpayers not by the employers
whose low pay is causing the
difficulties supposedly businesses are
drawn to states with right to work but a
study showed that those States also have
low taxes and inexpensive electricity
New Hampshire has relatively low taxes
but High electricity costs and moreover
we have a housing and a Child Care
crisis which it discourage workers from
coming to New Hampshire and even make it
difficult for our own Granite State
Workers to
work there is also a question of
fairness workers in the US and New
Hampshire already have the choice to
work or not to work for a company that
has a union if they work for a company
with a union and benefit from the
contract and rights that the union has
negotiated if they expected um then it
is only fair that they pay the union
dues for those
benefits um several analogies have been
made if one works but we know that if
one wants to shop say at Sam's Club one
pays the membership dues if you want to
try travel on a Turnpike you pay the
tolls there are alternatives I don't
have to shop at those shops and I don't
have to drive on the turnpike similarly
workers can choose to work in a
non-union shop and finally as a retired
public educator in New Hampshire I am
always pleased to hear from former
students and in the past year or so I
met a student in his early 20s who was
so proud of himself to be a member of
ibw which afforded him good paying job
training and promotion opportunities
retirement savings and the opportunity
to stay in his home Community we need
young workers in our grain State and for
the betterment of our workers their
safety fair business practices and the
New Hampshire way please vote this bill
you any questions for the
presenter seeing none testimony I
emailed it to you I
think thank you madam clerk you want to
read something from the
online
happy thank you Mr chair um I will say
there are some repetitions because
people did sign up twice but uh with
that caveat um the number of people who
signed in online to oppose to support
the bill 48 to oppose the bill,
two and then we have these too I don't
know if we can f these
back this is from the last
representative love could you pass all
right thank you very much for uh for
your
attention um this hearing
anyone yeah I always forget to bring it
it sits in my desk and I always forget
so I get my my water bottle use your
shoe earrings closed thank you very much
everyone for
coming
ready used
perf
did anyone hear what I said before
yeah uh because uh we're pushing some
early bills that have to be done next
Wednesday anyone that makes a
motion or um a Minority
Report um must stay here and um write
the blur before we leave because I have
to approve them and give them to the
clerk so um so she can have them first
thinging them Thursday morning got
o00 okay you mean today or next week
today you do yeah all
right thank you everyone opening the
executive session relative to the state
uh minimum wage House Bill 1322
representative avalani uh thank you Mr
chairman I move
itl motion is itl is there a second
second by Drago
discussion or you have the right to
speak to your motion thank you Mr
chairman
um not only should um employee employers
work out their wages um having an
accelerator takes it out of the hands of
good
representative stop thank you Mr
chairman um I I would um like
to I speak against the motion of itl uh
New Hampshire has not raised our minimum
wage since 2009 that's a very long time
um New Hampshire has the eighth highest
cost of living in the country um and um
although very few people right now are
making um the minimum wage mostly it's
tipped workers who if they come in and
have a slow shift then the employers
required to make up their uh make up
their salary to 725 an hour that's a
starvation wage um the bill as presented
is very conservative it starts out um
only raising the minimum wage to like
$927 an hour but then um a year from now
it would be 11 and it goes up to 17 um
by uh by 2025 and the um reason that um
I chose $17 is because the um MIT
minimum wage calculator or or excuse me
living wage calculator says that that's
the amount of money that a person would
have to make um in order to have a
decent um U value of of life and um a
decent quality of life so that's you
know that's why we're looking at $17 an
hour because I think one of the things
that we need to think about is the
quality of life of our constituents the
other reason that I think we need to
raise the minimum wage is because we are
currently in the middle of a worker
shortage and I every other um State
around us has raised their minimum wage
significantly and we are competing with
those States for workers and um this
$725 minimum wage is a is a red flag
to young people who are considering
whether they want to stay in the state
or people who are considering moving
here because minimum wage generally um
it it affects people at the at the
beginnings of their career and people at
the the lower end of the wage scale so I
mean I think it's part of our job as
policy makers to create conditions that
promote economic growth and right now
the limiting factor in growing the New
Hampshire economy is the labor force so
if we're not going to do things to um
make our state more competitive then
we're really hampering economic growth
in the state and I think that that's why
it's important to pass this Bill thank
you representative thank you
representative kahill followed by
bushard thank you Mr chairman um I would
U I would agree that the workforce is a
major problem as is housing as is child
care and this is why people need to make
more money to be able to afford those
things um personally I would have been a
bit a bit more gradual and but this is
what was offered and I'll support
itative
buard thank you Mr chair and be patient
I forgot my glasses but I want to say um
that I'm in opposition of this motion
because I know that there are workers in
my
city who work two or three jobs to pay
their rent heat as well as putting food
on on their table for their
families though this bill is not a
living wage bill it can help lift
individuals and families out of poverty
establish a degree of Economic Security
for them and reduce chronic anxiety and
stress often experienced due to income
insufficiencies employeers would benefit
from lower employee turnover and less
money spent on hiring and training
so far there is no empirical evidence
raising the minimum wage causes an
increase in unemployment or job loss in
fact a golden Sachs analysis of the 13
states that have raised their minimum
wage found that the states where the
minimum wage went up had faster
employment growth than the states where
the minimum wage remained at the 2013
level and we haven't raised our minimum
wage
since
2007 as a taxpayer I am also concerned
that many of these workers who will
benefit from this minimum
wage they'll depend on government safety
net programs to supplement their
salaries to meet their basic needs like
food shelter transportation and heating
I urge my colleagues to join me in
opposing this itl on this minimum
minimum Bill thank you Mr chairman
welcome representative um love followed
by Madam clerk thank you Mr chair I'll
be supporting this uh this itl motion
and uh my reasoning behind that is I
have a family member that uh you know 24
years old has a GED no College
whatsoever I had a a six-year run with
crack cocaine been been been sober for a
year and a half she has no no resume to
brag about whatsoever and she just just
got a job for $18,000 plus I mean $18 an
hour plus commission uh there's let's
let the let the the market dictate
thanks repr
Schultz thank you Mr chair
sorry um I get that anecdotal evidence
um for our loved ones around us can
influence our views on this I don't know
if you listened to my speech if you were
at the State House
um on session day when the $15 bill that
I was the lead sponsor on all my talking
points were about Ronald Reagan and his
value of hard work uh with the hope I
would win over some Republicans to the
cause uh one Republican did come over
and so for that I do think it was worth
it and maybe this won't change your mind
but you know I think there are pretty
compelling arguments to make that would
appeal to Republicans
um I know this because the data supports
this when you pull the average Granite
Stater and you say would you like New
Hampshire to have a higher minimum wage
than
$725 an hour at least the last poll I
saw that did only go to 15 the majority
of Republican voters in New Hampshire
supported this so Rank and file
Republicans are with us on this issue
this is a bipar an issue um why then
would we as a bipartisan body want to do
that and I would say to support
capitalism the market has failed Us in
this area 100 over
130,000 Granite Staters make less than
15 I'm sorry that I don't have that up
to date about how many make less than 17
but it's obviously going to be more than
130,000 Granite Staters with that high
of a figure all of these folks making
sub subpar
wages live in all of our districts
impacts our economy significantly and
our economy isn't as good as the
surrounding states that all have
essentially double uh what we have um
and I'll just end on this point because
I think it to me is the number one point
I will die on this hill this is the one
issue I will die on is issues of wages
and that's the notion of Working Poor we
live in America in the one of the
wealthiest States as represented of sto
poed out in the country we live in a
place of enormous wealth um certainly
true of the people who probably serve in
this body I can't say that I know that
for sure we are a privileged group and I
don't have a problem with privilege I do
have a problem with the notion of
Working Poor no one in America in the
grand gred State should work full-time
and not be able to pay rent or feed
their children or take care of the
basics much less have to struggle to pay
for medication or child care all the
other
things
um as a Catholic as a person of
moral uh I don't know I can't say that
I'm the best human being necessarily but
I try I just morally have a huge problem
with this the notion that we a wealthy
privileged State um would allow
something like working poverty to be a
concept that we perpetuate and so I just
urge you regardless of your vote today
think about that talk to your
constituents we need this if the if we
need to pass this in the near future and
it is beyond suffering at this point and
capitalism has not paid enough attention
to what the aspect of workers in a
capitalist economy and that as a value
in uh society and if we don't turn that
around uh it's going to hurt all of us
because it certainly has hurt the
state's economy
um I try to keep it brief thank you but
anyway there's there's my honest thought
repres
Sullivan thank
you um minimum wage keeps going up um up
and up and up in the states around us in
New Hampshire it goes up in the bills
that we propose
um the bill the first bill I was
involved with was a $12 minimum wage um
then it was $15 minimum wage now it's a
$17 minimum wage and and those are all
appropriate numbers for their time the
problem is we've not adopted any of them
um and I've said it before I'm
embarrassed to be in a state that does
not have a competitive minimum wage um
it hurts us as already has been stated
um it sends a message to Young workers
that we don't care enough about them to
provide the lowest wage earners a
competitive minimum wage um it's the
least we can do and I will oppose the
itl in favor of a different motion thank
you representative McKenzie followed by
Co
thank you thank you Mr chairman
uh I think uh if we look at this
strategically and we look at uh the fact
that there are 50,000 people leaving the
state of New Hampshire every day to work
in a different state than New
Hampshire if you look at the fact that
Massachusetts minimum wage is $15 an
hour a simple trip across the border
you're in the $15 an hour range if you
go to Vermont you're in the 13
1367 if you go to Maine you're in
145 so those people live on the
border and those people who every day
now I'm not saying the minimum wage
workers the all of that 50,000 but
that's a documented uh number that came
from an economic study that we were uh
that representative buer was nice enough
to give
us so just think think about this if
somebody can get in their car and drive
miles and make potentially $8 more an
hour why would they stay in New
Hampshire and there has to be some
consideration for this just
strategically looking at it we talk
about this all the time about workers
being you know we're losing workers we
can't attract them to the state of New
Hampshire and I can tell you just
looking at that economic report that
this Situation's going to get worse and
worse and worse and the predictions
about how many vacancies are going to be
in New Hampshire is staggering so we
need to start thinking about how we
going to keep workers here and one way
to begin the process of keeping workers
here is to not let people in other
states that surround us raise their
minimum wage to the extent that they
pull our workers out of the state which
is which is what's happening each and
every day so I I know the arguments
people say Well everybody's this is all
going to work out and the economy is
going to make it work out but as as
representative Sullivan
said the signal that we're
sending and it's not that we don't even
have a minimum wage in the books in New
Hampshire the only reason people have
paid $725 an hour is because of the
federal minimum wage we eliminated that
minimum wage in New Hampshire a few
years ago came back excuse me wrap it up
no I said I believe oh we we we got rid
of it and then we brought it back no I
don't think we did true okay my
apologies well what's still there is the
tip wage is still in the in the minimum
wage area but I don't think we ever
brought it back I might be wrong we'll
look at that again but that's a fact we
got to start thinking about Workforce
Development how we're going to keep
people in the state how we're going to
keep them engaged and this is one
area that everybody says well they're
getting paid 18 or 15 or that that the
market is really responding to this when
in fact if that's the case then what's a
big deal if that's the case then why
aren't we raising the minimum wage to be
competitive with other places and I did
Workforce Development with the aflc for
a very long time and wages make a
difference they make a difference and
when you can travel a couple of miles
and make a lot more money that makes a
difference thank you Mr chairman welcome
representative
C thank you Mr chairman um I'm going to
support itl on this I said a couple of
times here our federal government is the
one that hasn't raised the minimum wage
and I think our complaints need to go to
our federal government and I think that
our Employers in the state should be
able to set their wages and our
employees looking for jobs should be
able to demand the wage that they want
or find another job and um as we listen
to all of the right to work bills or All
the Right to Work testimony we've heard
I've heard time and time again they
don't want to work for a union shop they
can go get a job elsewhere well they
don't want to make $7.25 or whatever the
minimum wage is right now go find a job
elsewhere or tell the employer I'm not
going to work for that dollar amount
simple as that and move on and that will
correct the situation I listened to the
news last night hearing that McDonald's
is now charging I think it was
McDonald's in California they're
charging $18 now for a Hamburg meal and
people are complaining because this is
unaffordable well geez when you increase
the minimum wage at McDonald's to be $15
an hour what are you expecting you know
there will forever be an unaffordable
minimum wage because as the minimum wage
increase the cost of goods is going to
increase it just keeps going higher and
higher and then everybody else who's
paid above that is going to want their
increase and it just keeps going so the
federal government is not willing to
increase it I'm fine staying with where
it is and letting the employers
themselves
I don't disagree with a lot of the
things that were said to my left and I
will say what I said the last three
times a bill came in front of us I
really wish the house Democrat and house
Republican leadership will get together
get together and and come to an
agreement on this where we don't have
any escalations we don't have any uh
automatic increases um or we just make a
decision what the we all know in our
heads to be the minimum wage that are
going on in this state because I'm I
don't like being the punching bag of uh
of the state and this committee uh for
this this issue all the time um there is
solution uh but I'm sorry to say this
this bill is not it even though I do
respect uh representative sto which you
put
together uh everyone who uh has spoken
we going to vote uh anyone who would
like to speak if theyve already
spoken all right I'm going to take the
vote the motion on the floor is an
expedient representative kill thank you
Mr chair uh since you and I are I think
on on the roughly same page on this and
that's a start um would it be something
that we could uh defer till next week
and try to come up with a number just uh
or or even pass this and a floor
amendment that would say it's going to
be $14 an
hour
representative kale you ask me that
every year after I give my my speech of
wanting to resolve this issue once and
for all and and the the answer is coming
up with the
bill that enough members of both sides
will agree to and doing it here and
holding it for another week and an
amendment is not the way to do that um
respectfully um holding the executive
session now I agree with
you having once lived in New York it's
like the Mets maybe next
year oh or like the Red Sox um motion on
the floor is in expedient to
legislate Madame clerk um you please
call the role Vice chair seaworth yes
rep avalani yes rep Prout yes rep love
yes rep Boyd yes rep Mason yes rep c W
yes rep dgo yes rep gagy
yes ranking Dem Sullivan
no rep haken Phillips hackin Phillips
I'm sorry no rep kahill no rep D
sylvestro no rep Lloyd no Rett bushard
no Brett McKenzie
no the clerk vote no repair no rep sa
no Mr chair yes 10 to 10 representative
Sullivan you recognized for a motion or
whichever I move ought to pass motion on
the floor is ought to pass seconded by
representative
stab you're um recognized to speak to
motion
I think we've uh said all that needs to
be said about the the topic um I'm happy
vote anyone
else motion on the floor is ought to
pass it's been moved and seconded Madam
clerk please call the role Vice chair
seaworth no rep avalani no rep PR no rep
love no rep Boyd no rep Mason no rep
culcom no rep Dro no rep gagy
no rep uh ranking Dam Sullivan yes rep
haken Phillips hacken Phillips I again
sylvestro rep Lloyd yes R buard yes R
McKenzie
yes uh the clerk votes yes rep Clair yes
rep stab yes Mr
chair
no no recommendation 10 to
10 uh representative uh avalani and
representative St St will be writing the
blur moving on
to House Bill
1668 relative to the establishment of a
4-day work week representative Dro here
recognized for a motion yep I move itl
motion of the floor is inexpedient to
legislate moved by represent Dro second
by representative
Prout you're recognized to speak to your
motion okay well during testimony we
heard um that this they did some studies
and they actually found that a shorter
Work Week actually
kept Revenue the same for businesses or
in some cases actually increased
it and I couldn't wrap my head around
that and I had asked for some more
information which we never received or
at least I never did um so I just revert
back to numbers numbers are kind of what
I always use to fall back on and in New
Hampshire a lot of the
trades they charge by the hour they
might have a set price for big jobs but
um you know plumbers coming out to
repair your house it's by the hour
electrician whatever so if you're a
business as 10 employees
and now you go from a 40 hour work week
to 32h hour work week you're losing
eight hours of billable work per
employee that comes out to 80 hours a
week so I H I don't see how Revenue will
increase or even stay the same by
decreasing the work working hours so
part of the testimony we heard was well
you just hire more employees everybody
in this room both sides agree there's a
work shortage it's not easy just to go
out out and hire a new employee and to
make up 80 hours of billable labor that
would be over two employees now you have
to go find two new employees out of a
Workforce that already you can't find
anybody on top of that we learned last
time we had a little class on
unemployment taxes and all that so now
you're increasing the cost of your
business by having new employees you're
probably offering them benefits and
everything else so even to get your
Revenue the same now the cost of running
a business goes up um and that's just
the first half of the bill and the
second half of the bill talked about the
way we would pay overtime and to save
time I don't we don't really need to get
into all that but um the way it's done
right now is basically the
employer sets forth you know you can
either pay overtime per day or you can
pay your cumula of hours at the end of
the week over 40 you can pay for that so
having it mandated in a bill to pay a
certain way kind of takes away what's
always been the uh you know the the
option of a business owner himself so
and I don't really support bills that
force it one way and not the other and
for that reason I can't support this
Bill thank you representative
Sullivan I I think this is an
interesting concept um and I have uh
read and actually heard some radio
programs uh discussing the uh the 4-day
work week and I think uh in in some
circumstances um it would it would make
for a good you know experiment
um however to make it a a required part
of
our um workplace uh
is in many instances
uh difficult if not impossible um and uh
frankly maybe there will come a time way
down the road where this will will take
uh be be more appropriate and more
popular but right now
I think it's in the category of an
experiment um I hope people continue to
experiment with it um and get more data
to see if it see if more employers and
employees might benefit from it but uh
as a bill um it certainly it's not
something I can support so I would will
itl I don't see any other
hands to speak the motion on the floor
is oh right no motion the floor is
inexpedient to legislate to stay for the
vote please representative and then um
you can he's doing double duty two
executive sessions in two different
rooms um motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate it's been moved
in second we had the discussion Madam
CLP please call the rule rule oh um
representative
Boyd
yes Vice chair seaworth yes rep balani
yes rep Prout yes rep love yes it's his
idea uh rep Mason yes rep kcom yes rep
drgo yes rep gagy
yes ranking D Sullivan yes re haken
Phillips hacking Phillips I keep do is
it hacking or haaken it's hacking like a
computer hack thank you and yes I hope
my conditioned Behavior will fix that
next time um rep kahill yes rep D
sylvestro yes rep Lloyd yes rep Bard yes
rep McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes uh
rep Clair
yes rep stab yes Mr chair yes 20 to
zero any objection to consent
agenda seeing none
thank you representative uh House Bill
1023 FN relative to requiring employers
to provide notice of resources available
to support veterans with postraumatic
stress disorders representative Sullivan
you recognize for motion I move interim
study moved by represent suvan second by
rep representative alalani you
recognized to speak to your motion um
this is a bill that came to us with with
no sponsor presenting it um I'm not
enely sure what his motives were um the
sponsor didn't come yeah um he um there
is a identical bill that I understand he
wanted it in the Senate right so so B
bottom line is um the sponsor asked us
to itl this bill um I'm moving interm
study because I for one do not want to
be voting against veterans with PS PTSD
um so uh we can vote to study it rather
than um kill it because it's got a
better look um thank
you and if something gets messed up in
the Senate we have the bill
right any other
comments seeing none the motion on the
floor is inter room study it's been
moved in second we've had discussion
Madame clerk would you please when when
you have a second give me a second I let
her all right that's all I needed all
right please call the role um Vice chair
seaworth yes
rep
balani yes rep Prout yes rep love yes
Boyd that's all right uh rep Mason
yes rep culcom yes rep Dro yes rep gagy
yes ranking D
Sullivan yes rep hackin Phillips yes rep
kahill yes rep St sylvestro yes rep lyd
yes rep buard yes rep McKenzie yes the
clerk votes yes rep Clair yes rep stab
yes Mr chair
passes
uh okay
um next is House Bill consent calendar
objection all right house bill 1072 FN
relative to reiving employers from using
polygraph testing uh recognize
representative avalani for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move itl motion
on the floor is in expedient to
legislate moved by representative
love you're uh recognized to um speak to
your motion thank you Mr chairman um
some of the testimony
um give us pause to look at this and
um one question that came up was suspect
questioning if they needed to do a um
polygraph on them and this would
prohibit that so um for that reason and
amongst others um it shouldn't go
forward thank than
you there was another Sullivan thank you
um I'm not sure I'm a fan of doing
polygraph tests on uh prospective
employees um however um we didn't hear
about any employers that were actually
doing it other than perhaps law
enforcement which there is an exception
for um and I I guess I just I'm not in
favor of passing legislation that solves
problems that do not presently exist so
itl I see no other hands the motion on
the floor is an expedient to legislate
it's been seconded and we've had
discussion ready for the role Madam
clerk Vice chair seaworth yes rep
avalani yes rep Prout yes rep love yes
rep
Boyd rep Mason yes rep kcom
yes rep drgo yes rep gagy
yes ranking D Sullivan yes rep pack and
Phillips yes rep K Hill yes rep D
sylvestro yes rep lyd yes rep Bard yes
rep McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes rep
L Clair yes rep stab yes Mr chair yes 19
does zero the motion passes any
agenda thank you moving on to House Bill
1226 FN relative to the protection of
freelance employees recognized
representative Sullivan for a
motion I move um interim study motion
second FL is interim study seconded by
representative uh
Schultz you recognized speak to your
motion thank you um
I think the sponsor of this bill
acknowledged that um it really didn't do
um all of what he wanted it to um the
person who testified uh at length uh
who's in a freelance working situation
um I think also felt like they were sort
of grasping at straws um the um it was
it this is not a problem in search of a
solution well this is a problem in
search of a solution we just didn't find
it with this bill um so as an aside uh
during our discussion of it it was
suggested that there are some uh unions
out there such as the um musicians union
or the uh screen Screen Actors Guild or
the uh writer Guild who do Loosely um
pull together um groups of people who do
not have the same employer or do not
have even consistently um the same
employer individual ually um but it does
set some standards for their employment
and there there might be something to
work with there but uh bottom line is it
needs work um and um I think we should
encourage the sponsor to uh continue his
work on this and hopefully come back
you I initially uh felt that um this
bill should go to interim study um after
listening to testimony um online online
and um because I think it's well it's
not our
job to teach people what to do with
their bills and to tell them how to fix
them necessarily all the time it's
clearly something that is going on it's
a clearly postco type of situation uh it
even has a name you know now you know
gig employee or gig jobs or all these
other things that that go on um and uh
it it will be worth the exercise
and I say that in a polite way that
to understand what is allowed and what
is not by our department of labor rules
and our other rules regarding health
insurance and such so um again while I
don't think it's our our our job
necessarily to teach someone how to fix
their bills or to resolve their issues
um there's more benefit that can come
out of this for all of us uh and anyone
who wants to stay on this committee for
years to come because this is will
continue to be an issue that needs to be
motion seeing no other hands the
motion's been made second and we've had
discussion Madame Clark would you please
call the role the motion
is in inter study yeah
226 um Vice chair seaworth yes rep
balani yes rep Prout yes rep love yes
rep Boyd
rep Mason yes rep kulam yes rep dgo yes
rep gagy
yes ranking Dem Sullivan yes rep hackin
Phillips yes rep Cahill yes rep D
sylvestro yes rep Lloyd yes rep Bard yes
rep McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
replic Clair yes
rep stab yes Mr chair yes 19 to zero the
motion
passes uh any objection to consent
seeing
none that's right because it's
yeah and that's why I didn't call the
first one no right correct it's not
calendar no it's it's a it's a same as
retained it's just the second year this
is this is our version of retained in
year two yeah so we're talking to
here all
right our yes our last bill for the day
I need to be out of here in 15 minutes
because mom's got an appointment with Mr
Sullivan as well as an appointment House
Bill 1315 FN relative to the definition
of wages for the purposes of
unemployment compensation representative
seaworth I move it
motion on the floor is itl second Mr
chairman seconded by representative
alalani representative Sullivan seaworth
you're recognized to make uh yeah speak
to your motion thank you very much our
the prime sponsor and our colleague
representative McKenzie has asked that
we itl this bill not to try to put words
in his mouth but uh he offered that the
concept wasn't really ready um to be
Advanced as legislation so
that see seeing no other hands to speak
the motion on the floor is inexpedient
to legislate it's been moved and
seconded it's time for the role Madam
clerk you all are quicker than me at
this moment you're going to give her a
second here F you know work expands to
fill time so you ladies it it's
sometimes it's a little
harder what the L the ladies and
do
okay all right Vice chair seaworth yes
rep avalani yes rep proud yes rep love
yes rep
Boyd rep Mason yes rep Co
yes rep drgo yes rep gagy
yes ranking Dem Sullivan yes rep pack
and Phillips yes rep Cahill yes rep D
sylvestro yes rep Lloyd yes R Bard yes R
McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes r l
Clair yes rep Stow yes Mr
passes it'll be on the consent agenda we
have one more piece of business
representative seaworth um a question to
representative Sullivan on the bill that
I submitted that had to do with the
probate um we had talked about whether
it was appropriate to have a study
committee on that and just wanted to get
an opinion whether we want to try to
schedule that it's on our calendar for
next Wednesday to be exact um is that
something we want to formally do a
subcommittee do we want to uh work
offline
I it it can be removed from ex we could
delay it it's not one of the early bills
it has to get done it uh it seemed like
something that uh you as sponsor beli
needed some uh some work in Amendment um
is is that correct so uh I came up with
the with a number $3,000 was is the
number in that bill it sounded like from
the discussion that other members might
have preferred a different way of
calculating that
um and
that I am open to anything that that
would find a an a resolution to it I'm
not I'm not against my number but I'm
I'm not particularly for it either okay
um I I I think coming
up in the spirit of 20 to nothing um it
might be nice to to work on it to make
to make sure that we've got something
that is a consensus I mean I don't think
it's a a volatile issue frankly I think
if we did nothing it probably wouldn't
be the end of the world um but because
it's not like anybody's been knocking
our door down to uh fix this thing um we
we had to go looking for it um but but
uh just the same if we're going to fix
it if we can fix it in a way that people
feel is uh um you know most acceptable
um by most everyone that'd be a good
idea and put something else in the
consent calendar so yes I I I would be
um be willing to work on it so I guess
Mr chairman maybe an appropriate way to
schedule that is to defer the executive
session and schedule a subcommittee when
we finish our meeting
a week from now maybe I uh I will notify
um our assistant that we will be
removing that bill from executive
session next week and then if you and
representative s would get me the
appropriate members
um so we can announce it next week how
many are we looking for two to each to
each um representative buard did you say
you would do
it buard and Sullivan will be
rard Sullivan avalan and
seaworth oh were you saying you were
volunteering you have a question
volunteering okay okay yes question
sounds like a good time is there any
reason we can't announce that today and
get started um with the four members
have now been
announced
um I don't want to take everyone's time
um if you guys can come up with a
date um I'll get it in the calendar you
let me know today you guys look at your
calendar I think the suggestion was to
meet uh next Wednesday right um after
the executive session yes immediately
the executive s that's why I said okay
okay I apologize I guess I dismissed
that
one no no no uh so uh I'm announcing a
subcommittee what's the bill number
now
on House Bill 1201 representative
Sullivan
bushard seaworth and avalani it will
meet um after the executive session next
Wednesday 13th any other business to
come before this
committee cenan thank you very much if
you have amendments or if you have
anything coming up uh let me know also
we are pushing obviously because we have
Bill Early bills next week we have had
all of our hearings so we will have a
little time I'm not going to be cramming
we have till March 15th to get some of
the other things done I will meet with
representative Sullivan we'll work out a
schedule of when we're going to meet and
um and we'll let everyone
know thank you very much for your time
everyone
today thank you did every one of these
you